ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
OF FOREIGN STATE
ADMINISTRATION. INFORMATIONAL
HEARING NOW IN ROOM FOUR THREE
SEVEN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE. MAKE YOUR WAY
OVER TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL GET
STARTED. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN WELCOME TO SUBCOMMITTEE
FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION. I
HAVE ENOUGH TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY.
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION TODAY
WE ARE IN ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. AND
THIS ROOM CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
A FEW MEMBERS OF MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP. SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICTPHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER IN THE CAPITAL. AND FOR
THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WILL RESTATE THIS ONE
PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. IN
THE ROOM WISH TO SPEAK THEY
WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I
LASSEN TO APPROACH. THE
MICROPHONE I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE HE WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
COMPLETE. OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA AND ELLIE- ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY. WE
ARE ACCEPTING. PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING.
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS FOUR THREE SEVEN ONE THREE.
ONE FIVE IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING. PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF
FOUR THAT THE NUMBER FOR
BUDGETS OF FOUR AT ASM THAT CA.
DOT GOP WE HAVE FIVE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD NINE ISSUES
TO BE DISCUSSED TODAY WE WILL
TAKE MEMBER QUESTIONS AFTER
EACH ISSUE WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING. AND
WE WILL BEGIN THIS FIRST- JUST
TO SET THE TONE FOR THIS FIRST.
A PANEL WHICH IS RELATED TO.
THE ET DE OVERSIGHT DISCUSSION
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE WE
WILL A LOT OF PROXIMALLY THIRTY
MINUTES FOR THE CONVERSATION.
FOR THE FIRST PANEL- WE HEAR
FROM EDT THE BUDGET ACT
PROVIDES THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM WITH A
DIFFERENT BUDGET MODEL WHICH
EDT WILL DISCUSS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PANEL IS TO IDENTIFY WITH
RESOURCES EATING IT NEEDS. IN
ORDER TO MEET THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE OUR PANELISTS
TODAY INCLUDE NANCY FARIAS
CAROL WILLIAMS BOTH WITH EDT.
CHAS ALAMO WITH ELLY ELLS
OFFICE AND MARK HUMANNESS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET'S
GET STARTED. AS MISS FARIAS
THAN MS WILLIAMS READY TO GO
THE RED ROCK AND ROLL. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE'RE WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS- I
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT WE WERE
GOING TO PRESENT ON- ANYTHING
OTHER THAN OUR BUDGET ISSUES
WHICH CAME UP IS PREPARED TO DO
ONE ONE MOMENT MISS VERY AS WE
HAVE AN ECHO WITH YOUR AUDIO SO
ONE SECOND HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LET'S TRY AGAIN
CAN YOU DISCOUNT FROM ONE TO
FIVE. ONE TO. ACT ALL RIGHT
WHAT YOU HAVE FOR BREAKFAST
DISCONNECT. BUT I USED TO ASK.
IF I CAN MAY DAY THE RADIO.%
BECAUSE FOR ALL- WE SO I AM
SORRY AND WE ARE- MY COLLEAGUE
AND I ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE- CALEB
WILL BE- PRESENTING ON OUR
BUDGET ITEMS. OKAY WHY DON'T WE
START WITH CALEB THEN AND
PERCENT ON YOUR BUDGET ITEMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE ARE
BECOMING ALSO FAST FRIENDS WITH
ALL OF THESE- EDT HEARINGS I
KNOW YOU LOVE THEM. THANK YOU
FOR. WHENEVER CALEB IS READY.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES- SO IT'S JUST A
RELATION TO OWN WHAT WAS
CAUSED. BY AN ON THE CHAIR IN
IN THE AGENDA SPECIFIC TO EASE
BUDGET- WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY-
VIA THE BUDGET ACT IT'S A
PROCESS THAT ALLOWS EASY TO
ADJUST OUR APPROPRIATIONS-
TWICE A YEAR IN BOTH OCTOBER
AND APRIL. EIGHT ALLOWS FOR
ADJUSTMENTS TIED TO WORKLOAD-
ANY CHANGES IN EXPENDITURES DUE
TO CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY-
FLUCTUATIONS TIED TO CHANGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL OF FEDERAL
LAW- SUCH AS ALL THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE PASSED. ON DURING THE
PANDEMIC- AND AS I MENTIONED
THIS DOES OCCUR- TWO TIMES A
YEAR FOR BOTH CURRENT YEAR AND
BUDGET YEAR WE CAN MAKE THESE
ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
PERRANCE PROGRAM- IN THE
OCTOBER OUR OCTOBER ADJUSTMENTS
WHICH WERE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. EDT HAD
SUBMITTED AN REQUESTED A
CURRENT YEAR INCREASE OF SIX
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND TEN
POINT SIX- PERSONNEL YEARS AND
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. IN ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGET AUTHORITY THAT IS ALL OF
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS- FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR CD INCLUDED AN
ADJUSTMENT 430-009-0070 SIX
POINT SIX PERSONAL YEARS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILLION
IN FEDERAL RESOURCES WELL.
AGAIN WANTED JUST TO MENTION
THAT ALL OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
IN IN FEDERAL RESOURCES HI
THERE ARE YOU AYE BASED FUNDING
FOR THE VARIOUS PANDEMIC.
PROGRAMS BE HAPPY TO ANY
FURTHER OF OUR REFI IT JUST.
OKAY I'M GONNA OPEN IT UP TO-
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IF
THEY HAVE ANY CURRENT QUESTIONS.
YES OKAY WE HAVE OUR SHARE OF
BUDGET MR TANG. SO OFTEN JUST-
JUST OPENING QUESTION THE JUST
MORE OF A COMMENT ON SORT OF
THE STATE OF EDT HIS SON THEIR
DEGREE YOU REALLY DIDN'T DO
MUCH IN TERMS OF A BUDGET
REQUEST A BUDGET AUGMENTATION
CAN YOU SORT OF WALK US THROUGH
OUR. YES I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION I JUST CHECKING- SO
AGAIN WE GET A JUST OUR BUDGET
IT'S JUST IT'S NOT A FORMAL BCP.
WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET
ACT THAT ALLOWS US TO ADJUST
TIED TO WORKLOAD. AND SO AGAIN
OUR OUR WORKLOAD ESTIMATES AT
THE TIME OF REVISED. WE DID
MAKE SOME SIGNIFICANT
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR DEPARTMENTAL
ADMIN BUDGET AND OUR BENEFIT
BUDGET. AND AS I MENTIONED
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS IN IN THE
YEAR THAT WERE IN. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
RESOURCES. AND THEN IN BUDGET
YEAR IT WAS A SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX MILLION INCREASE IN
FEDERAL RESOURCES. I SHOULD
MENTION THAT- THAT DOES WORK ON
ESTIMATES WERE BASED ON FAIRLY
PESSIMISTIC ECONOMIC OUTLOOKS
AND SO WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT
THIS- APRIL WHEN WE SUBMIT OUR
ARE. UPDATED WORKLOAD ESTIMATES
THAT THOSE MORE THAN LIKELY MAY
COME DOWN SLIGHTLY- BUT ALSO
WITH THE ADDED NUANCE OF THE
MOST RECENT PASSAGE OF THE
STIMULUS ACT IN DECEMBER. AND
THEN ALSO WHAT'S OCCURRING AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE MOST
RECENT- BIDEN'S. FEDERALLY
PACKAGE IF THAT GETS PASSED
THAT WILL FURTHER- PROBABLY
ADDED WORKLOAD INTO- NOT ONLY
THIS YEAR BUT THE NEXT YEAR.
THAT WASN'T PREVIOUSLY
ANTICIPATED. SINCE THE YOU FEEL
THAT- UP TOLD THE NOW AND
EIGHT. YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO WORK THROUGH THE
BACKLOG AS WELL AS TO RESPOND
TO REQUESTS BECAUSE- BASED ON
THE EXPERIENCE OF ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES IT DOESN'T APPEAR
TO. IT IS UNCLEAR TO US THAT
YOU HAVE ADEQUATE. NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE. WAR YEAH YOU READ THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE AN ADEQUATE
NUMBER PEOPLE OR IS IT THAT AN
OFFICE TECHNOLOGY I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS. BOB I'LL
GENERALLY ANSWER THAT I MAY-
PUT THAT ONE BACK OVER TO
EITHER NANCY OR CAROL BUT AGAIN
I. THINK IT'S I DON'T NEED ANY
GENERAL INTEREST THE SUPPORT TO
THE TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THIS IS NOT. THIS IS THIS IS
WHERE WE TALK SPECIFICS AND WE
TALK MONEY SO IF YOU CAN'T
ANSWER SPECIFICALLY THOSE KNOWN
TO FEW COULD HAVE SOMEONE WHO
CAN. SO MET MISTER CHAIR SO AT
ASKING OF MENTIONED WE ARE
FEDERALLY FUNDED. SO I MEAN IF
YOUR QUESTION IS WHY ARE WE NOT
ASKING FOR MONEY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW FROM FROM
THE STATE FUNDS. FOR THAT WELL
WITH THE WITH MY QUESTION MIKE
MY QUESTION TO CALEB AND YOU
CAN ANSWER NANCY'S- IS. TIED TO
IT DOES THE DEPARTMENT HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES. IN TERMS OF
STAFFING TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO TURN. R. X.
INTO IS IN OUR EXPERIENCE
HASN'T REALLY BEEN THE CASE. SO
WE WERE A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED
THAT THERE WAS NO- IN A BUDGET
REQUEST BROUGHT FORWARD. SIX SO
I CAN ANSWER THAT- THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION I MEAN
YES WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
THE FEDERAL RESOURCES AVAILABLE
WE CONTINUE TO. YOU KNOW WORK
WITH THE- THAT I DID
MINISTRATION AND LOOK FOR
RESOURCES- AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES- TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE- YOU KNOW
THE PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU. IT TOOK JUST- JUST
FOR THE FOR THE RECORD JUST A
COUPLE THINGS FROM MY DISTRICT
OFFICE JUST TO NOTE. BASED ON
THE MOST BASIC CASES IT DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE. SIX WEEKS BETWEEN
SUBMITTING. IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY
GETTING PAID. ARE WE STILL
SEEMS TO BE A FAIRLY. A FAIRLY
LONG TIME FOR THE MOST SIMPLE
OF CASES- THE NOTATION HERE IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT SEEMS TO
NEED MORE TIER TWO. SPECIALIST
OR OTHER STAFF WERE TRAINED TO
RESOLVE ISSUES SO THAT THE WORK
DOESN'T GET KEEP GETTING.
PASSED ON TO OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES I THINK WE I'VE MADE A
NOTE THAT FEELS LIKE. IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES OF ALL BECOME
SORT OF CASE WORKERS FOR EDT
OVER THE LAST YEAR. IN THE AND
THEN LASTLY THAT ANYTIME THAT
THERE IS A TECHNOLOGY ISSUE. IT
DOES RESULT IN HOURS OF OUR ALL
OF OUR COLLECTIVE. THE STAFF
TIME IN SO WE'RE WE'RE SEEING
AN INCREASE IN CASES. FROM
CONSTITUENTS WITH EXTENSIONS DO
NOT AUTOMATICALLY FILE SO WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- YOU
KNOW WHY WHY THAT BLIND. SORT
OF AUTOMATIC FILING DOESN'T
OCCUR AND WHY. ARE WE MAKING
PEOPLE GO THROUGH. GO THROUGH
SORT. OF MANUAL MANUAL FILE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I ME
I. CAROLE SIMPSON. THE ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION YOUR APPS RIGHT
SO WE HAVE. BUDGET WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT YOU'RE
WHERE WE HAVE MOUNTAINS OF
DEFERRED WORK LOAD UP TO THIS
POINT WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON ONE
POINT SIX MILLION FROM THE
STRIKE CHANGE NOW THAT THOSE TO
FOR WORKLOADS HAVE COME TO BEAR
WE ARE ON THE RAMP UP YOUR
STAFFER ABSOLUTELY CLEAR-
CLAIMSFILER'S WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE'RE WORKING- ROUND
THE CLOCK THIS WAS A BIG PAST
WEEKEND WHERE WE- MADE A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO WORK. THE
CASES THAT YOUR STAFF REALLY
HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED TO AN THAT
THEY'RE WORKING LITERALLY ON
OUR BEHALF YES WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES YES WE HAVE THE
BUDGET WE ARE RAMPING UP ON THE
RESOURCES WHETHER WE NEED AN
AUGMENTATION FROM THE PRIVATE
SIDE WE ARE. HIRING WE ARE
TRAINING A MEASURE WHERE ALL OF
THAT HIRING AND TRAINING WAS
DEFERRED FOR MANY MANY MONTHS.
IN THE FALL. THANK YOU CAROLYN.
I'M SO. THE GO AHEAD I DIDN'T
THINK THERE IS A DVD I WANT TO
ALSO ADD- YOU KNOW 9% OF THE
CLAIMS. ARE GOING THROUGH THE
AUTOMATIC PROCESS- AT 10% YOU
KNOW THAT IS NOT GOING THROUGH
THAT THE AUTOMATIC PROCESS ARE
REALLY THE ONES THAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THAT'S CAUSING SOME
OF THE BACKLOG THAT YOUR- YOU
KNOW REFERRING TO AND THAT'S
WHAT REALLY WHERE WE'RE PUTTING
ALL OF OUR- YOU KNOW OUR TIME
AND RESOURCES AND GOING
THROUGH. THOSE 10% THAT PERCENT
GREAT GREAT THANK YOU TO JUST
COME BACK TO ON. THE PREVIOUS
DEPUTIES COMMENTS ON. WHAT DO
YOU THINK YOU'LL BE FULLY
STAFFED UP OBVIOUSLY IT'S ONE
THING TO HAVE MONEY ONE OF THE
THING TO BE ABLE TO HIGHER THAN
TRAIN PEOPLE SO. YOU KNOW BASED
ON YOUR BILL YOUR BASED ON JUST
THE TIME FRAME WHAT WHAT DO YOU
THINK YOU'LL ACTUALLY. BE FULLY
STAFFED. END OF MARCH OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SO IT'S BEEN
ALMOST A YEAR SINCE CALIFORNIA
WHEN THE LOCKDOWN THE PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK NEEDING
UNEMPLOYMENT ALMOST HERE WE
STILL CALIFORNIA'S NOT GETTING
DESERVE BENEFITS. AND ASKING
FOR ASSISTANCE IN ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE SO WE'RE HEARING
FROM SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS IS
ON A CALL AND- EDT EMPLOYEE
TOLD THEM TO CALL THEIR
LEGISLATORS. AFTER THAT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN SO JUST IN
ANSWER TO THAT BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID WE'VE HEARD IT FROM MY
STAFF WE FEEL THE PLAY CLOSE TO
TWO THOUSAND CALLS AND HELP
INDIVIDUALS OUT WIRE EDT STAFF.
TELLING THE CONSTITUENTS TO
CALL THEIR LEGISLATORS. THANK
YOU VERY IS WITH AT T. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE HAVE HEARD THAT AND
WE HAVE. EXPLICITLY TOLD STAFF
MANAGERS AND STAFF TO NOT- YOU
KNOW TELL- SAY THAT TO
CLAIMANTS WHEN THEY CALL AND
THEY ARE DIRECTED NOT TO DO
THAT- WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
CHOOSE TO DO THAT WITH OUR
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
NOT SAYING THAT- AND WE WILL DO
IT AGAIN- I UNDERSTAND. YOUR
CONCERN WITH THAT AND THAT IS
NOT THE DIRECTION GIVEN BY EDT.
OKAY OUR CONSTITUENTS WERE
FINALLY GETTING PAID BENEFITS
FROM LAST FEDERAL THE LAST
RELIEF PACKAGE BEING TOLD BY E.
D. THIS EXPECTS ANOTHER DELAY
WITH THE NEXT EXTENSION. AS
WELL SINCE EXPECTING THE SAME
TYPES OF PROBLEMS WITH THE
PROGRAMMING AND I. D. ME IS
THIS TRUE. CAROL WILLIAMS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE- JUST TO PUT
SOME INFORMATION IN CONTEXT.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF JANUARY
FOR THE NEW PROGRAM WE'VE PAID
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
ATE MY HALF BILLION DOLLARS-
PHASE ONE IS COMPLETE CLAIM IT
SHOULD BE AND CASE STATUS.
PHASE TWO WILL BE COMPLETED BY
MARCH SEVENTH AB- WE'RE NOT
EXPECTING WERE NOT AWARE OF ANY
DELAYS IN THIS NEXT PHASE SO
FOR THAT IT IF I'M SORRY IF YOU
COULD REPEAT THE QUESTION WAS
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO ID ME
THANK YOU WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE LONGER THE
EXTENSION. EMPOWER FALLS IS
WITH PROGRAMMING AND ID ME
HELLO OKAY. SO THERE'S A THIRD
PHASE AND THAT'S THE MIXED
EARNER THAT IS PHASE THREE
THERE IS BUT TO ONE OR TWO
STATES THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THIS EXTREMELY COMPLEX PART OF
THE NEW EXTENSION PROGRAM. EDT
WE HAVE NOT THAT IS A PHRASE
THREE WERE WORKING ON
REQUIREMENTS AS WE SPEAK. UP IT
IS EXTREMELY TECHNICAL AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT AND COMPLICATED
BECAUSE IT HOLES IN WAGE
EARNERS AND FOLKS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING THE GIG ECONOMY
WHICH IS WHY IT IS TAKING SO
LONG AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A VERIFICATION FOR
EACH OF THOSE TYPES OF
EMPLOYMENT. SO THAT IS THE THAT
IS WHAT'S TAKING SO LONG ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE. WE ARE NOT
ANTICIPATING I DO NEED A LASER
IMPACTS WITH THE PHASE THREE IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
ANOTHER ISSUE CONCERNS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING DENIED
THEIR EDT PAYMENTS BECAUSE
YOU'RE UNABLE TO WORK AWAY FROM
HOME. THE CITY TO SUPERVISE
THEIR CHILDREN WHO WERE IN
DISTANCE LEARNING IN FACT MANY
OF MY CONSTITUENTS WERE BEING
TOLD BY EASY WORKERS. THEY'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY HAD JOBS
BUT HAD TO QUIT SIX DAY HOME TO
BE WITH HER SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. IS THIS A MISTAKE- OR.
THE PARENTS INELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CAROL WILLIAMS- WITH
THE FACT THAT THE BLADE OUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. IF IT'S DUE
TO A OLD IT REASONABLE AREN'T
ANYTHING ELSE THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE
AND HAS TO DO WITH- RESUMING
THE DEFERRED WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEGUN SINCE THE BEGAN. IN
EARNEST THE BEGINNING OF
JANUARY AND THESE
DETERMINATIONS AND HOW THE
CLAIMANT IS ANSWERING THE
QUESTION IT'S NOT THE CLAIM IS
FALSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
EATING IS ABSOLUTELY LOOKING
AT. AS THE ANTS NOW ANSWER THE
RESPONSE IN TERMS OF- THE
DETERMINATION WORK THAT WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE TURN OFF FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME. AND ARE NOW
RESUMING AND QUITE HONESTLY I
DO BELIEVE SOME CLAIMANTS ARE
GETTING CAUGHT UP IN THAT BAND
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT. AND WE
HAVE TO FIX WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND SWEEPING THROUGH WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CONTINUE IN
THE DETERMINATION PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY'RE RECEIVING THIS
INFORMATION FROM US THERE. THEY
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT WE HOPE TO HAVE A
FIXED WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK WE
CAN A HALF. CERTAINLY CAN
REPORT OUT FRIDAY DENTAL DURING
ALLEGE STAFF CALLS ON THIS
PROGRESS. OKAY THEN THAT'S
IMPORTANT- ALSO LATE LAST YEAR
WE NEVER TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
EASY EMPLOYEES. HAVING-
COMPUTER AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
I'LL TOLD BY THE I BELIEVE THE
DIRECTOR I'M NOT SURE TOLD ME.
ON DURING OF OUR CALL. BUT I'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT YOU ALWAYS SEE
SOME EMPLOYEES. YOU ONLY HAVE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE THAT WORK
FROM HOME. ON SOME BASIS. BUT
MOST OF THE PLAYS WERE TO WORK.
SO SOME TAKEN DESKTOPS HOME-
SOME OF THE GIVE A LAPTOP BUT-
I WAS TOLD THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
ALL THE EMPLOYEES. ARE WORKING.
FROM P. D. ON THE COMMITMENT
BECAUSE SINCE HE- DOESN'T
OPERATE ON CITRIX. THEY HAVE TO
USE A STATE ISSUED EQUIPMENT IS
THAT CORRECT. FOR ANY WORK WE
DO REQUIRE STATE ISSUED
EQUIPMENT IT SHOULD NOT BE AN
IMPEDIMENT THOUGH BECAUSE
WHETHER IT'S A DESKTOP BEING
DEPLOYED. M. OR A LAPTOP THE
WORK IF THE WORK ALLOWS ITS
LENDS ITSELF TO BE WORKING FROM
HOME THEY SHOULD BE AT HOME
WE'VE DONE ASSESSMENTS ON
TELEWORKING- SINCE THIS FALL TO
ENSURE ALL THAT COULD WORK. THE
PROBLEM IS WE HAVE VERY
DISTINCT CRITICAL WORKLOADS
THERE'S UNFORTUNATELY STILL
PAPER BASED AND BOTH EMPLOYEES-
SAFELY HAVE TO COME IN THE
OFFICE WHICH ALSO CONTRIBUTES
TO THE LATE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
EVERYBODY IN THE SAME. OFFICE
AT THE SAME TIME AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH OUR
APPEALS WORKLOAD IT IS
ABSOLUTELY PAPER BASED WE'RE
WORKING ON AUTOMATING IT. SO
THAT WERE IN IT ONE DEPLOYS ARE
ABSOLUTELY HEALTHY AND SAFE TO
DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO THE
OFFICE THE WORKLOAD CAN PRESUME
AT A NORMAL PACE OF TURNING IT
AROUND WITHIN TWO TWO WEEKS TWO
TO THREE WEEKS. WHAT IS THE
SAFETY REASONS THAT REQUIRE
LIMITED STAFF FOR THE PAPER
BASED WORK THAT IS A PRIORITY
FOR US TO CREATE AN AUTOMATED
FASHION. OKAY AND I'LL LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS IS FOR THE
CONSTITUENT FROM LAST FRIDAY
SUPPORT WHEN MY STAFFERS INTO
THE EMAIL. I NEED HELP PLEASE.
I CALLED UNEMPLOYMENT I WAS ON
HOLD FOR TWO AND A HALF HOURS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WAS PUT THE
RUN OUT OF A PUT THE RIGHT
HOURS WORKED. BECAUSE I HAD SO
MUCH INFO REPORT. THE GUY TOOK
ALL MY INFO WE HAVE MY NUMBER.
WHEN ASKED LOOK AT MY CLAIM. I
WAS DISCONNECTED. IF HAVE MY
NUMBER HE SHOOK ME BACK. I'M
OVER HERE. I KNOW IF THERE WILL.
BE THREE THE HOLES OF MICHAEL.
THANK YOU FOR THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE
FOUGHT WILL FIRED BUT A LOT.
BUT I GUESS THE BIG THING IS
THAT WELCOME I KNOW YOU'RE
PLEASE ENTER A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF STRESS AND I GET
THAT. AS OUR BY OUR EMPLOYEES
AND OUR DISTRICT OFFICES THAT
TAKE THESE CALLS FROM PEOPLE AT
THEIR WITS END SO ACCESS BEEN
GOING OFF FOR A LONG TIME. AND
IT IN MY MIND. THE TIME TO PLAY
CATCH UP IN IN FOR MISTAKES IS
OVER. IT SHOULD BE PRETTY MUCH
FINE TUNED WITH THIS. AND WITH
THE ROLLOUT OF ID MAYBE. THAT
WAS BOTH THE- HELP SPEED UP
PLAYING BUT STILL WE STILL HAVE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF CLAIMS THAT
ARE STILL BEING. HELD UP IN THE
PROCESS SO. INELIGIBLE STATE
ROUTE FIFTY A YEAR LATER. AND
WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT NEXT
MARCH'S DIGITAL MISTER KING
EARLIER. THAT IT'LL BE BETTER
BUT IT'S- AT SOME POINT- IT TO
ME JUST DOESN'T CUT IT IS HAS
BEEN. PROBLEMATIC FROM DAY ONE
SO I'M HOPING ISRAEL IS THE
CONSTITUENTS OF THIS GETS
BETTER BECAUSE- YOU KNOW PEOPLE
ARE- IT'S JUST. WHEN FACED WITH
TRYING TIMES- PEOPLE VERY
DESPERATE SO THANK YOU. OKAY.
YES HI THERE THIS IS A THE
SUMMER BLACKIE AND I JUST WANT
TO KNOW- IF YOU HAVE ANY
UPDATED CUMULATIVE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT HAS BEEN LOST
VERIFIED FIVE VERIFIED FRAUD.
OVER THROUGH THIS- SYSTEM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEEDED VARIOUS-
WITH EDT- WE HAVE NOT
CALCULATED THE NEWEST NUMBER
YET BUT WE ARE AND WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH THAT- ONE OF
THE- STATISTICS YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN WAS THAT WITH A STOP PAY
THAT WE DID BACK IN- AT THE END
OF LAST YEAR- ABOUT 40% OF
THOSE THAT WENT THROUGH ID ME
ABOUT THAT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION UP THE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION THAT WENT THROUGH IDEA
MADE. ABOUT 40% OF THOSE HAVE-
CLEARED ID ME SO THAT'S ABOUT
WHERE WE'RE LANDING IT'S NOT
WERE WERE YOU KNOW SORT OF
WAITING FOR THAT YOU KNOW FOR
TILL THE END OF THE MONTH SORT
OF THING JUST TO JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY WHO IS- WHO
WANTS TO GO THROUGH I. D. NI
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
THROUGH I DO NEED TO VERIFY
THEIR IDENTITY. AND WE WILL
HAVE UPDATED STATISTICS UPDATED
NUMBERS- SOON ON THAT OKAY SO
IS THAT DATA OR WHAT DATA
RESULTS KENNEDY SHARE FROM ITS
A THOMAS REUTERS FRAUD
DETECTION SOFTWARE CONTRACT
WITH US CENTER- AS FAR AS THAT
THAT. REUTERS- DATA IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE YES AND. SEVEN- SO
THE SO THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE- THE ONE
POINT FOUR THAT WENT THROUGH
THE THOMAS REUTERS- BROAD
CRITERIA AT THE END OF THE YEAR
AND AS I JUST MENTIONED THE ONE
POINT ONE THAT WENT THROUGH I
DEEM ME I'M WE DO HAVE A BREAK
DOWN OF THAT ONE POINT ONE IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE
WERE HAPPY TO- FOR THAT TO YOU
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WENT
OUT IN THE PRESS RELEASE LAST
WEEK AND ALSO HAS- GIVEN TO
STAFF ON THE FRIDAY CALL WE'RE
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
I'D LOVE TO HAVE THAT IN MIND
WHERE FINAL QUESTION IS HOW
LONG ARE THESE CONTRACTS
EXPECTED TO LAST WITH THE-
THOMAS REUTERS AND- ACCENTURE.
THE EXTENT YOUR CONTRACT IS FOR
ONE YEAR- AND THAT WAS JUST
ENTERED INTO IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS- BUT THOMAS REUTERS
CONTRACT I HAVE TO SAY I'M NOT
I KNOW WE ENTERED INTO THAT
CONTRACT LAST OCTOBER I'M NOT
SURE OF THE TIME FRAME ON THAT-
I BELIEVE THAT CONTRACT IS
ONLINE BUT I'M CERTAIN I'M I'M
HAPPY TO LOOK THAT UP FOR YOU
CAN GET BACK TO YOU. ON THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LUCKY WE HAVE A MISTER TO
ONLINE. GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF LET ME START FIRST
WITH A FOLLOW UP ON A QUESTION
FROM OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR
MR TANG SO MANY BUSES
LEGISLATORS WE ARE ASKED EVERY
DAY EVERY HOUR EVERY DAY WHAT
MORE CAN YOU DO TO FIX CDD AND
WHAT I'VE BEEN SAYING FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AS WE
PROVIDE A DVD WITH AS MUCH
BUDGET AS A REQUESTED AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
AT THIS MOMENT. YOU'RE NOT
ASKING FOR NEW BUDGET MONEY
YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY SAYING YOU
YOU YOU YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT- YOU BELIEVE YOU NEED YOU
JUST NEED TO DEPLOY THEM AS
QUICKLY AS YOU CAN I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT'S- WHERE.
YOU THINK WE ARE AT THIS POINT.
YES I THINK MY COLLEAGUE CAROL
SAID IT SAID IT BEST AT THAT
DATE WE HAVE THE THAT THE MONEY
THE RESOURCES BUT WE NEED WE DO
NEED TO HIGHER UP- AND THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW. OKAY SO
ASSUMING THAT THERE ARE SORT
OF. TWO AREAS THAT I THINK WE
OUGHT TO BE SPENDING AND I WANT
TO JUST UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BETTER. SO THE FIRST IS AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND I KNOW YOU
READ THE ANALYSIS AROUND THAT
AND IF I MAY FOR JUST A MOMENT.
SORT OF LAID OUT- SO AS YOU
KNOW- LEGISLATORS WE'VE BEEN
RAISING THIS ISSUE OF LANGUAGE
ACCESS FOR THE BETTER PART OF A
YEAR. WE AS OF THIS MOMENT HAVE
NOT YET GOTTEN MUCH INDICATION
OF WHAT NEXT STEPS CAN BE TAKEN
TO IMPROVE THIS. AS YOU KNOW
LAST AUGUST WE SENT YOU A
LETTER- BECAUSE IN PART A
LETTER REFERENCED THE FACT THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT. THE STATE WAS
IN VIOLATION OF STATE LAW UNDER
THE DONNELLY AUTOREACTIVE. YOU
ALSO KNOW THAT RECENTLY THEIR
BAND. LEAGUE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
BELIEVE THAT EDT IS IN
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAWS
INCLUDING THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
OF NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. YOU
ALSO KNOW THAT THE EDT STRIKE
TEAM REPORTED THAT QUOTE
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT FLUENT IN
ENGLISH. FACED INSURMOUNTABLE
BARRIERS TO RECEIVING
ASSISTANCE. AND AS THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS TODAY NOTES
THERE BEEN NUMEROUS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
RAISED THIS ISSUE. FOR QUITE
SOME TIME THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS NOT YET SEEN A PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE LANGUAGE ACCESS AND I
KNOW YOU ALSO KNOW. I HAVE A
BILL THIS TOPIC- THAT MANY OF
US ARE VERY INTERESTED IN AND I
KNOW I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. ALSOJUST
SAY. TO THIS PERSON IS WILLIAMS
ALSO NO YOU ARE RECENTLY
JOINING THE TEAM SO- THERE'S A
LOT OF THIS PREDATES YOU BUT
WHAT I'D LIKE TO ASK IN
SUGGESTS THAT I REALLY DO HOPE
WE TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS. TO
ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK. WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
FUNDING ATTACHED TO THIS- WE
KNOW LANGUAGE ACCESS DOES NOT
COME WITH WHAT YOU IF WE CAN'T
ACHIEVE IT WITHOUT- WITHOUT
INVESTMENT AND UNLESS YOU CAN
TELL ME. THAT YOU THINK SOME OF
YOUR CURRENT DOLLARS CAN BE
REDEPLOYED. TO ENSURE LANGUAGE
ACCESS FOR EVERYONE. I SUSPECT
WE NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
AROUND FUNDING SO I WANT TO
JUST GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON. A
WHAT I'VE JUST LAID OUT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT NEEDS
THE VARIOUS- EDT AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT- WE SHARE YOUR
CONCERN- SURROUNDING LANGUAGE
ACCESS THERE IS NO QUESTION
CAROLINE I HAVE HAD IN. AND THE
DIRECTOR OF HAD MANY MANY MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT. IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE DO- VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU- ON YOUR LEGISLATION
ON THE PROPOSALS OF- MANY
LEGISLATORS ON THIS ISSUE- YOU
KNOW BEFORE IT'S SORT OF AN
INTERESTING. THING BECAUSE
BEFORE CULTIVATED- YOU KNOW
THEY WERE ACTUALLY MORE
RESOURCES BECAUSE PAPER AND
PHONE WERE MORE AVAILABLE- TO-
PEOPLE. WHO WERE TRYING TO CALL
AND I MAY HAVE HAD LANGUAGE
ACCESS ISSUES- AND SO WE'VE
TAKEN THAT UNDER CONSIDERATION
OBVIOUSLY AND- YOU KNOW
INTERNALLY WE HAVE. A TEAM OF
PEOPLE. THAT ARE FROM ALL OF
OUR BRANCHES- ACROSS THE NEEDY
AND THE POOR FOCUSED ON SOME
SHORT TERM ALSO SOME LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS BUT- SHORT TERM WE'RE
LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE- MULTI
LINGUAL. MIGHT MULTI LINGUAL
ACCESS- AMOUNT HAVING A MULTI
LINGUAL ACCESS PORTAL ON THE
WEBSITE- EXPANDING TRANSLATION.
OF THE U. Y. APPLICATION OF
COURSE AND YOU KNOW LASTLY OF
COURSE I'M STREAMLINING DAHLE
MULTI LINGUAL PAPER APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT. THAT WE CURRENTLY
DO HAVE- THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
STREAMLINED CLEARLY- WE'VE ALSO
EXPANDED SOME OF THE EDT
RESOURCES INTERNALLY I THINK-
SOME OF YOU KNOW THAT- WE'VE
DEVOTED- A SENIOR LEVEL
STAKEHOLDER POSITIONS THAT.
WILL BE HIRED SOON- DEVOTED TO
ELLIE ELLIE P. ISSUES- IT. THIS
PERSON WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENGAGING THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING
THAT WE HEARD FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AS WELL AS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE- IN JUST HELPING
US- GO THROUGH SOME WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THAT YOU KNOW
YOU Y. ACCESS ISSUES- WE ALSO
HAVE REACHED OUT TO OTHER
STATES AND OTHER SISTER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
JUST AS THE START OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE OTHER- SOME OF OUR SISTER
AGENCIES ALSO PROVIDE SERVICE
TO PAY. YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
DOING WE'RE TRYING FIND YOU
KNOW GET. FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
BEST PRACTICES ARE- AND WE DID
AND I THINK EVERYBODY DOES KNOW
THIS BUT- LAST SEPTEMBER. WE
IMPLEMENTED THE SPECIFIC STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATION- REGARDING
ELLIE P. ACCESS WHICH WAS
BASICALLY JUST WE REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT- THAT MANAGERS HAVE
TO FIRST APPROVE THE DECISION
BY ACCLAIM WRAPPED WENT THAT U.
P. R. AS THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN THE CALL CENTER TO ACCESS
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS LINE THAT
WE HAVE. SO THEY NO LONGER HAVE
TO DO THAT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE DID. AWHILE BACK- AND
JUST IT JUST MAYBE CLOSE. YOU
KNOW ONE THING COLLECTIVELY I
KNOW THAT WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKE TWICE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'VE TALKED WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THAT. THE THE GREAT
RECESSION AND SORT OF YOU KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THAT- AND
YOU KNOW WE DO AS WE MENTIONED
WE DO HAVE THE RESOURCES. NOW
YOU KNOW BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD AFTER THIS LIKE
AFTER WE HAVE SO WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES NOW BUT IN A YEAR. OR
IN TWO YEARS WHEN WE NO LONGER
HAVE THOSE FEDERAL RESOURCES
THAT'S REALLY WHEN WE NEED TO
TAKE A DEEP DIVE AND LOOK AT IT
AND OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO BE
PREPARED. FOR UP TO THAT MOMENT
SO WHILE WHILE I DO SIT HERE
AND SAY THAT YES WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES NOW. YOU KNOW WE WILL
HAVE TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON. ON THE FUNDING AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED GOING
FORWARD AFTER THIS YEAR IS DONE
AND AFTER THE FEDERAL RESOURCES
DRY UP. WE APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWERS VARIOUS I CERTAINLY. I
THINK I SPEAK FOR ALL OUR
COLLEAGUES AND SAYING THAT
AFTER THE NEXT SIX TO TWELVE
MONTHS WE HOPE TO SOLVE THIS
FOR THE LONG HAUL SO THAT WE-
DON'T HAVE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS.
I KNOW THAT LANGUAGE ACCESS IS.
IT'S NOT TRUE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN- FIX
OVERNIGHT- GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
ONLINE CHANNELS WRITTEN
CHANNELS- A CALL CENTER
CHANNELS. BUT BUT THIS IS. OUR
OFFICES HAVE JUST BEEN UTTERLY
OVERWHELMED AND- AND I THINK
BUT FOR THE BILINGUAL OR
TRILINGUAL STAFFERS THAT MANY
OF US HAVE IN OUR OFFICES. MANY
OF THESE BOOKS WOULDN'T GET ANY
ASSISTANCE WHATSOEVER AND IT
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY TAXING. FOR
FOUR TEAMS SO. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION I HOPE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO REALLY. ASK YOU TO
MAKE DECISIONS QUICKLY AT LEAST
FOR THIS CURRENT PERIOD. THE
OTHER COME TO HAVE A LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS- BELIEVE IT OR NOT
EDT IS NOT THE ONLY STATE
AGENCY THAT IS STRUGGLING WHEN
IT COMES TO LANGUAGE ACCESS
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT CHALLENGES.
IN THE HEALTH CARE CONTEXT IN
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICE CONTEXT
WHERE FOLKS ARE REALLY FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND- I
WONDERED IF AS A STATE WE OUGHT
TO. FIGURE OUT HOW TO CREATE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE WHERE
LANGUAGE ACCESS TEAMS ARE ABLE
TO WORK ACROSS DIFFERENT. AREAS
TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION AT
LEAST SWAT TEAMS THAT CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SOLVE IT IF
NOT. BE THE TRANSLATORS
THEMSELVES SO I KNOW YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT IT BUT THESE ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS I LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING WITH YOU
ABOUT- A SECOND TOPIC I WANT TO
COVER AND THIS IS SOMETHING I
WAS VERY SURPRISED NOT TO SEE-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST
FORM. HAVE TO DO WITH FRAUD AND
I WOULD SAY. HAVE TO DO WITH
FRAUD ON TWO LEVELS FIRST. IN
ADDRESSING AND INVESTIGATING
THE FRAUD THAT HAS HAPPENED. AT
I REMEMBER. IT AT AT A PREVIOUS
HEARING. WE WERE TOLD THAT YOU
DO THE ONLY HAD SEVENTEEN
INVESTIGATOR STATEWIDE AND
HOPING THAT NUMBERS HIGHER NOW.
BUT I WANT TO GET A SENSE. OF
WHERE THAT IS- AT YOU ALSO KNOW-
MANY OF US IN THE- WE HAVE BEEN.
BY BYE BY OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT THEY
ARE WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED TO
INVESTIGATE THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE FRAUGHT. AND SO WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY PROPOSALS TO
GRAPPLE WITH FRAUD BOTH TO
ADDRESS IT THERE BUT ALSO. OF
THE STATE AUDITOR REPORTED THAT
QUOTE EDT FACES AN IMPENDING
WORKLOAD. TO ASSIST VICTIMS OF
IDENTITY THEFT WHOSE PERSONAL
INFORMATION WAS USED. TO FILE
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS GIVEN THE
HIGH LEVEL. A POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS AND PROCESS
SEES FOR DRESSING THEM EDT IS
UNDERPREPARED TO HANDLE THIS
WORK SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. I
THINK STATE AGENCIES NEED MORE
RESOURCES TO GO AFTER THE BAD
GUYS BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ARE HONEST
CALIFORNIANS WHO'VE BEEN
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT WHO
CAN'T GET THEIR MONEY. WHO ARE
WHO ARE WHO ARE LITERALLY
CRYING ON THE PHONE BECAUSE
BANK OF AMERICA WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAD MONEY
STOLEN FROM THEIR ACCOUNTS WE
NEED TO ASSIST OUR CONSTITUENTS
AS WELL AND SO I WANT TO ASK
YOU. WHAT IS THE PLAN AROUND
EXPANDING RESOURCES AROUND
FRAUD HOW ARE YOU GOING TO DEAL
WITH BOTH OF THESE ARE
CATEGORIES OF WORK AND- AGAIN I
JUST HAVE TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WHY DID YOU REQUEST ANY
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH THIS OR
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN. DEAL
WITH IT WITH THE RESOURCES YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GETS THE VERY AS I CAN I CAN
ADDRESS PART OF THAT I THINK
THE SEVENTEEN- INVESTIGATORS I
THINK THAT WAS MY FAULT I
DIDN'T- MISSPEAK WEEK. WE HAVE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS NOT- BUT
MUCHHIGHER BUT THERE WE HAVE
THIRTY TWO. PHYSICIANS WE HAVE-
HIRED MORE PEOPLE IN THE
INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION- ONE OF
THE FIFTH WAS THAT- WORKING
THROUGH THE- THE COMPUTER IT'S-
YES TASK FORCE WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S. OFFICE WE
HAVE A DEDICATED MORE RESOURCES
TO INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION TO
HELP. THE WHEN THERE ARE CASES
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
WORKING ON AND WE CAN HELP
TOLD. SOME OF THAT DATA FOR
THEM WE'VE WE'VE ACTUALLY HIRED
BRENCHLEY IN THE PROCESS. RIGHT
NOW OF HIRING I THINK SEVEN.
HELP THE DA'S PULLED BY. TO
PULL. THE DATA IN ORDER TO HELP
THE D. WITH THE- OUR LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATION. THEY
JUST JUST ON THE OTHER PIECE OF
IT AS FAR AS- ASKING FOR MORE
RESOURCES AND I CAN PUT MY
COLLEAGUE- ADDRESS THE TEN
NINETY NINE ISSUE BUT WE DO FOR
RESOURCES IN THE FAT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE HAS
BEEN SOME OF SEVERAL GRANTS
THAT WE'VE RECEIVED- FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WE HAVE
YOU. IN THERE IT IS TO BE USED
TOWARDS FRAUD AND THAT IS WHAT
WE HAVE DONE WE HAVE- USED IT
FOR THOMSON REUTERS WE'VE
ACTUALLY USED IT FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION. WE ARE
APPLYING FOR ANOTHER- GREAT-
GRANT MORE GRANT MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO- TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME OF THE- THE
OTHER YOU KNOW FRAUD- SOLUTIONS
THAT WE HAVE. THIS WILLIAMS ARE
OTHERS GIVE OTHER THOUGHTS ON.
I DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
KNOW. YEAH FOR A ONE TO NINETY
NINE ISSUE IS A VERY REAL
ISSUES WE ALL KNOW IT IS
ABSOLUTELY TAX TIME AND-
INDIVIDUALS ARE- EXPERIENCING
FOR THE FIRST TIME WHEN THEY
RECEIVED A TEN NINETY NINE G.
THAT THEY PERHAPS ARE A VICTIM
OF FRAUD. THE CALL THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING THE AMOUNT REPORTED-
CONCERNS THEM AND SOME OF THEM
HAVE LITERALLY NEVER FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT SO OUR MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE SHARING WITH THEM
THAT WE HAVE ON OUR WEBSITE IS
THAT IF YOU- IF YOU ARE A
VICTIM. OF FRAUD YOUR HAVE A
TEN NINETY NINE G. WE
ABSOLUTELY WILL WORK WITH YOU
WE HAVE STOOD UP. FOR CLINICAL
WRITTEN CLAIM IT BUT FOR INTO.
TO THROUGH GIVE US EVERY OF
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO YOU
JUNE HAVE THE NOT HAVE TO CALL
A- THE- TO THE PORT. THEY PER
INTERNET. IT GOES DIRECT TO OUR-
OUR STAFF THAT ARE. WORKING
THIS. THEY CAN MAKE THE
DETERMINE. BASED ON THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IF IT'S
COMPLETE. AND WE MAKE THE
DETERMINATION THAT IF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS IN FACT. NOT THE
RECIPIENT OF THE- OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT FUNDS WILL
DISASSOCIATE BACK FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS. FROM THAT INDIVIDUAL
GIVE THEM AMENDED TEN NINETY
NINE G. TO SHOW THAT THEY DID
NOT RECEIVE THE BENEFIT NO
COUPLE MORE. COUPLE OTHER
PIECES OF INFORMATION WITH THAT
THE IRS HAS ALREADY SAID IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ON THE WEBSITE. AND
I DO BELIEVE WE PROVIDE A
DIRECT LINK FOR THIS
INFORMATION. FOR PEOPLE THAT
FEEL THAT THEY ARE NOW THAT
THEY ARE VICTIMS OF FRAUD THEY
HAVE A TEN NINETY NINE JEEP
BECAUSE THIS AGAIN THIS IS A
NATIONAL ISSUE. DON'T YOU DO
NOT HAVE TO WAIT ON YOUR STATE
DEPARTMENT. WE'RE CATCHING UP-THERE TO BOTHER TAX REPORT
RETURNS AS ACCURATE THEY DIDN'T
RECEIVE IT THEY SHOULD NOT
REPORT IT. THE TAX DEPARTMENT
THAT TAX WHAT THE- UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
PROVIDING THE CLAIM IT AS WELL
AS THE IRS. WITH THAT CORRECTED
INFORMATION AND WE KNOW THIS IS
A VERY HEIGHTENED. TIME BUT WE
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO USE THE
PORTAL- CERTAINLY CALL WE
BROUGHT IN SEARCH STAFF WE
HAVE. A BETTER MAXIMUS WE
BROUGHT IN THREE HUNDRED FOLKS
TYPICALLY STOP THIS INDIVIDUAL
TEN NINETY NINE G. LINE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
VICTIMS AND I JUST BE FINDING
OUT ABOUT IT. THROUGH THE
RECEIPT OF THE TEN NINETY NINE
G. WE DID GO THROUGH OUR TEN
NINETY NINE G. FILE WE HAVE
SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION. WE
CLEANED IT OUT WE DID OUR BEST
TO CLEANSE OUT THE ONES THAT WE
CERTAINLY KNEW WERE FRAUDULENT.
BUT WE HAVE TO HEAR PROCLAIM
IT'S FURTHER FOR THAT WE HAVE
TO HEAR FROM INDIVIDUALS FOR
THE REST OF THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM WITH. A CORRECTED OR
AMENDED. TEN NINETY NINETY.
THANK YOU. I SO WHAT I'M HERE
FOR YOU IS- YOU DON'T NEED TO
RESTORE. IT'S A OF JUST THE
WORD OUT TO OUR- AND HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE. DURING
THIS TIME PERIOD. THAT IS
CORRECT WE HAVE THE BUDGET
DOLLARS AND FOR ALL OF OUR
WORKLOADS WE CONTINUE TO ADD
RESOURCES WE HAVE THE BUDGET.
WE'RE ADDING RESOURCES THROUGH
HIRING AND VENDOR STAFF IF
WARRANTED. THANK YOU OKAY. A.
B. YEP SUPER HELPFUL IF YOU HAD
A ONE PAGER SOME VERY SHORT
COMMUNICATION DOCUMENTS
TRANSLATED TO DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THAT WE CAN EASILY
GET OUT. THE BOX. ABSOLUTELY
CAP THAT WE WILL LIKELY NEED TO
DO ADDITIONAL TRANSLATIONS BUT
WE'LL TAKE THAT BACK THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU. WHY DO I HAVE
ONE FINAL QUESTION RELATED TO
THE BUDGET REQUEST AND THIS
INVOLVES A TOPIC THAT. I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US HAVE TALKED
ABOUT. PUBLICLY BUT THIS HAS TO
DO WITH THE FACT THAT YOU ARE
REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO MAKE THE
INTEREST PAYMENTS ON THE
FEDERAL LOAN. TO PAY BENEFITS
BEFORE CALIFORNIA'S
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND BECOMES INSOLVENT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM ON A HOLD
OFF ON THAT QUESTION FOR THE
SECOND PANEL SINCE THAT'S WHAT
THE SECOND ISSUE IS ABOUT. I'M
SORRY THE- I CALEB ADDRESSED HE
HE RAISED HE RAISES ISSUE WE
ALREADY DISCUSSED IT SO I'M
HAPPY TO ASK IT LATER BUT I
KNOW HE ALREADY BROUGHT THAT
WHY DON'T WE HOLD OFF UNTIL WE
DO THE SECOND ISSUE SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A MORE IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ACTUAL
BUDGET REQUEST. OKAY THANK YOU.
THIS FONG AND I'M SORRY TO ME
TO CUT YOU OFF A TO DO THAT
WITHOUT YOUR LAST COMMENT
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. SO WE
COULDN'T GO BACK TO THAT
QUESTION ON ISSUE TOO WE CAN GO
BACK TO THE QUESTION. THANK YOU
OKAY MR FONG. I THANK THE
CHAIR- IN READING THE ANALYSIS
IT MENTIONED THE- THAT THE
SECONDARY BACKLOG. HAS
SURPASSED THE MILLION CLAIMS.
AND I WAS JUST. CAN YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE IF THE IF THE STATE
EARLY BUT WHAT IS THE CURRENT
BACKLOG. AND WHAT IS YOUR
TIMELINE. I KNOW THAT YOU'RE A
MENTION TO THE CHAIR- THAT-
BUDGET THE- MENTION IN THE
BUDGET CHAIR THAT- IT MARCH AND
APRIL IS GONNA GET BETTER BUT-
DO YOU HAVE. MONTHLY BENCHMARKS
YOU'RE TRYING TO MEET. AND
ADDRESSING THE BACKLOG HOW DO
YOU APPROACH THIS BACKLOG ISSUE
AND WHAT WITH HOW FAST CAN YOU
GET. THIS THE BACKLOG ED RESULT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAROL
WILLIAMS OF THE TRY TO BEAT
THEM. TRY TO BE BRIEF BUT
COMPLETE. BOB BACKLOG IS
DEFINED AS A CLAIM IT TAKES
MORE THAN TWENTY ONE DAYS TO
ISSUE THE FIRST OR FURTHER-
PAYMENT FOR YOU TO BE ABLE
ISSUE- A DISQUALIFICATION. AS
YOU STATE WHEN YOU REFERENCE
THE- THE NEW BACKLOG
REFERENCING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE COMPLETED 1100% OF THE ONE
POINT SIX MILLION BACKLOG
CLAIMS IDENTIFIED BY THE EDT
STRIKE TEAM. I'M NOT WITH THOSE
WERE CLAIMS THAT WENT BACK FROM
APRIL ALL THE WAY THROUGH
SEPTEMBER. THE COMPLETE.
PRESENTLY ON OUR WEB- IT SHOWS-
EDV. OR THE CLAIMANT OR CLAIM
IT NEEDS TO TAKE ACTION ON ONE
POINT ONE MILLION CLAIMS THIS
IS THE DASHBOARD FROM THE
STRIKE TEAM. AND AT THAT POINT
IN TIME IT WAS EXTREMELY USEFUL
FOR EASY TO UNDERSTAND ALL OF
ITS WORKLOADS RATHER NOT CLAIM
IT NEEDED TO TAKE ACTION OR EDT.
HOWEVER IT IS HARD TO
DISTINGUISH THE TWO FROM THE
DASHBOARD SO FOLLOWING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITORS
RECOMMEND RECOMMENDATION EVEN
THE IS ADJUSTING THE DASHBOARD
TO BETTER ILLUSTRATE HOW MANY
CLAIMS ARE IN THE QUEUE WAITING
FOR ATV ACTION BEYOND TWENTY
ONE DAYS. I WILL BE USER
FRIENDLY AND IT SHOULD BE OUT
WITH THE NEXT TWO WEEKS ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WAITING MORE THAN TWENTY
ONE DAYS FOR RESOLUTION OR
FIRST PAYMENT OR CONTINUE
PAYMENT. FROM EIGHTY THESE ARE
THE NUMBER OF THE CLAIMANTS
WERE EDB NEEDS TO TAKE ACTION.
THE BACKLOG IS THE RESULT OF
RESUMING ALL OTHER CRITICAL
WORKLOADS THAT IS YOUR WE'RE
WE'RE DEFERRED WHILE EIGHTY
FOCUSED ON THE ONE POINT SIX.
SO THE ONE POINT SIX WITH
COMPLETED BUT WITH FEBRUARY
FIRST ALL OF THE DEFERRED
WORKLOADS ARE NOW IN FRONT OF
IT. WE ARE. DOING A RISK
ASSESSMENT ON THEM. AND IN THE
WORK PLAN TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
BECAUSE THERE ON WE ARE DOING
DETERMINE. SO THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THE STRIKE TEAM GAVE US
WAS A GREAT TOOL TO LOOK AT ALL
THE WORK THERE'S THERE ARE A
LOT OF WORKLOADS. AND BE ABLE
TO BE AGILE INCLUDES RESOURCES
SO WHILE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE
WAITING- WE ARE MAKING A
CONCERTED EFFORTS TOWARDS THAT
GROUP AS WELL ALL OTHER GROUPS.
SO WITH THE ADDITIONAL STAFF
THAT WILL BRING ON BECAUSE-
ANOTHER REASON FOR THE BACKLOG
IS FOR. FOUR MONTHS FIVE MONTHS
EVEN IF YOU DID NOT HIGHER AND
THIS IS THE FIRST WRITING
RECOMMENDATION SO THAT THERE
WAS A FULL FOCUS ON THE ONE
POINT SIX. CERTAINLY HAS HAD
ITS CONSEQUENCES. CONSEQUENCES
IT RESOLVE THE ONE POINT SIX
BUT HERE WE ARE TODAY NEEDING
TO MOVE FORWARD WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE DOING. OUTLINED BY THE
STRIKE OF THE STATE AUDITOR IN
DETAIL AND- EIGHTY DEGREES
1100% AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME I HOPE I
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. SO- SO
I JUST WANT YOU TO HAVE A LOT
OF NUMBERS THERE SO AND THEN WE
JUST MAKE SURE I GOT I GUESS I
GET THIS. CORRECTLY THE U. I.
BACKLOG AT THE STARTING
SEPTEMBER WAS ONE POINT SIX YOU
CLEAR THAT. THEN YOU HAVE. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. FIVE
THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT ARE BEYOND
TWENTY ONE DAYS PENDING. BUT
THEN THERE ARE. DEFERRED CASES.
THAT STILL EXIST. AND THAT
WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE THAT
THAT'S HOW WE GET TO OVER. A
MILLION CLAIMS THAT. IN TERMS
OF. TOTAL THANK YOU FOR THE
CLERK. THE ONE POINT OR THE
CLAY THAT ICE ABOUT THAT'S WITH.
IN THE CURRENT DASHBOARD THAT'S
ON OUR WEBSITE. THAT FACTORS
IN- CLAIM OR ACTIONS THAT
CLAIMANTS NEED TO TAKE. SOME
FIGURING ONCE CONCERNED WITH
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED BECAUSE WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO OUTREACH
TO LET THE CLAIM ITSELF YOU
HAVE TO RETURN EVERY TWO WEEKS
AND RECERTIFY YOUR CLAY.
REMOVING THAT OFF THE VIEW. SO
THAT YOU WILL ONLY SEE THE
AMOUNT OF WORK. CLAIMS THAT EDT
NEEDS TO ON THE DEFERRED WORK
IS STILL BEING ADDRESSED IT IS
HUGE. IT IS A CLEARLY ADDRESSED
IN THE STATE AUDITOR REPORT AND
IT REQUIRES A RISK ASSESSMENT
BECAUSE IT IS SO HUGE THERE IS
NO WAY. BUDGET RESOURCE IS A
SIDE THAT WE CAN- NOT ONLY
RESUME THE WORK BUT BE CURRENT
IN A VERY SHORT ORDER IF WE
DON'T CHANGE OUR PROCESS IS WE
HAVE TO CHANGE THE PROCESS WE
HAVE TO CHANGE THE WAY WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW WE MADE
DECISIONS. STILL BEING IN LINE
WITH ALL THE A WELL
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT IS WHY THE
STATE AUDITOR CALLED OUT EDT
YOU NEED TO DO A RISK
ASSESSMENT ON THAT WORK DON'T
JUST DON'T TURN IT ON BECAUSE
IT'LL TAKE YOU. A VERY LONG
TIME TO GET CURRENT AND THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ANYONE SO
OKAY. THE DEFERRED INTO
DEFERRED WORK IS NOT PENDING
CLAIMS THIRD THAT'S THAT'S THAT
THE DATABASE AS THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S THE CALLS THAT HAVE GOT
EVERYTHING ELSE. SO RIGHT SAID
SO THEN- RIGHT NOW THEY'RE ALL
IF THE DASHBOARD IS BEING
ADJUSTED BUT THERE'S TWO AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CLAIMS
THAT EDT HAS TO ADDRESS. THAT
ARE THE ONLY ONE DAYS OR
FURTHER. AND THEN THERE ARE THE
OTHER CLAIMS ARE CLAIMS THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS TO FOLLOW UP
WITH. EDT ONLINE TO ENSURE THAT
THAT PROCESS IS RESUMED. OR
CONTINUES. THAT IS CORRECT AND
THE- WHY THE ALL BE ALWAYS BE
CONFLICT CLAIMS WHAT WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE CLIMATE BUT
THEY'LL ALWAYS BE THESE CLAIMS
WITH THE CLAIMANT HAS TO TAKE
ACTION BECAUSE- OF. A LOT OF
THE TIME I MEAN THEIR PRIMARY
IS TO BE RE EMPLOYED RIGHT THAT
IS THE PRIMARY PURPOSE. AND
WHEN THAT OCCURS YOU OFTENTIMES
THEY WILL WALK AWAY FROM THE
CLAIM UNBEKNOWNST TO US- BUT
IT'S A CRITICAL STEP THERE SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE GOING TO
DISASSOCIATE. THAT BROKE FROM
THOSE THAT ARE EARNESTLY
WAITING FOR EDB TO TAKE ACTION
WE'RE GONNA KEEP OUR EYE ON IT
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE OUTBOUND
CALLS THAT WE HAVE SINCE
OCTOBER TO THE GROUP OF
CLAIMANTS. THAT WERE REMINDING
THEM- AND THEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HEARING- YOU KNOW I FOUND
EMPLOYMENT I DON'T NEED MY
CLAIM I'LL GO BACK AND CLOSE IT
FOR YOU SORTS NOT ON YOUR
BOOKS. WE DON'T WANT WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT TO THE
CLEAREST PICTURE OF THE WORK IN
FRONT OF US SURE. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE FOCUS AND
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THEY MAY STILL NEED
ASSISTANCE. THEY ARE STILL IN
NEED. SO ABSOLUTELY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
COMMUNICATING WITH THEM AND
THAT THERE'S A PROCESS AND A
PROCEDURE IN PLACE SO WHAT.
WHAT ARE WHAT IS THE EASY DEEP
PROCEDURE TO ENSURE THAT. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU THAT THEY CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU OR IF YOU
HAVE OR- AND WHATEVER THEY NEED
TO DO TO TRY TO GET THE CLAIM
RESULT. MOST THE CLAIMANTS
HAVEN'T ARE YOU WHAT ONLINE
ACCOUNT THIS IS HOW THEY DO
BUSINESS WITH US AND IT WORKS
WELL WE SEND. MESSAGES TO THEM
WE SEND EMAILS TO THEM
REMINDING THEM AND WE ALSO
STILL MAKE OUTBOUND CALLS TO
CLIENTS THAT HAVE. THAT ARE
NEARING THAT THE THEIR BEYOND
THE TWO WEEKS THEY HAVEN'T
RECERTIFIED. TO CONTACT THEM
AND MAKE THEM AWARE YOU KNOW.
THE MONEY IS HERE ARE YOU
ELIGIBLE YOU STILL NEED DO YOU
STILL MAKE THIS BENEFIT BECAUSE
WE'RE HERE FOR YOU READY TO GO-
WERE YOU IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
YOUR APPOINTMENT OR YOUR NEEDS.
OKAY AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO MENTION TO JUST OF
MY COLLEAGUES TO THAT WE ARE
STILL GETTING PHONE CALLS AND
BILLS MAYBE THE INDIVIDUALS.
ANY ASSISTANCE SO THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU CAN
PROVIDE US. IN IN RE. TO
ENSURING THE THOUSANDS OF.
UNDER FOR. AND NO THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE HEARING. AND IF THAT'S
THE CASE. THAT THAT THAT'S A
DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT NUMBER-
AND SO THE- THE EDITION FROM
NATION WOULD BE. HELP ON THAT-
IN TERMS OF THE- IN TERMS OF
THE PROTOCOLS IN IN TRAINING-
WHAT I GET A LOT IN TERMS OF
PHONE CALLS TO MY OFFICE AND
I'M SURE OTHER MEMBERS OR TWO
IS THAT. CLAIMANTS ARE ARE
CALLING AND TALKING TO ET
REPRESENTATIVES ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE AND THEN THEY'RE
GIVEN DIFFERENT OR CONFLICTING
INFORMATION WHAT IS THE
TRAINING PROTOCOL TO ENSURE
THAT. IF AN INDIVIDUAL CALLS
THAT THEY'RE GETTING THE SAME
INFORMATION CONSISTENTLY
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES YOU KNOW
THERE ARE WHAT'S AND THERE
THERE AND THERE THERE'S A LOT
OF ANXIETY. AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO GET INFORMATION TO YOU BUT
IF THEY'RE GETTING CONFLICT
INFORMATION THAT THEY
INADVERTENTLY CAUSES MORE
CONFUSION AND COMPLICATIONS.
YES BOB CAROLINE'S THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS ONE SET OF BOOKS
FOR OUR STAFF. IT IS ONE
PROCEDURE MANUAL AND IT IS NOW
ONLINE I'M SURE IN THE PAST
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE- OUR
INFORMATION WAS NOT ONLINE FOR
OUR STAFF IS ALL ONLINE. AND IT
IS THE SINGLE SOURCE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEND REMINDERS TO
THIS FEEDBACK IS GOOD IT COMES
IN THROUGH- OUR BI WEEKLY
SOMETIMES WEEKLY. WITH YOUR
STAFF THAT WE NEED TO GET IN
THERE AND REMIND STAFF AND
PRESENT THIS INFORMATION MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW THEY'RE
UNDERSTANDING THESE MESSAGES SO
THAT THE INFORMATION IS
CONSISTENT BUT IT IS A SINGLE
SOURCE OF INFORMATION. SO THERE
SHOULD NOT BE CONFUSION AND
AGAIN- WE DEFINITELY REGRET
THAT OKAY. AT THE END OF THOSE
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT I MEAN
THEY GO BACK TO THE TO THE OUR
FIRST CONVERSATION I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
REDEFINING AWAY THE PROBLEM.
THAT THAT PROP THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IS STILL NEED HELP
AND THE PEOPLE CALLING INTO
OFFICE STILL NEED HELP IN THE
WORD WE'RE GIVING THEM
ASSISTANCE- AND MY LAST
QUESTION I DO APPRECIATE. YOUR
DEPARTMENT ASSIGNING LIAISONS
TO EACH OF OUR OFFICES- TO HELP
US RESOLVE. THAT THE CASE IS
THAT OF INDIVIDUALS ARE CALLING
EVERY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN EVERY
STATE. SENATOR- IS A WAY TO.
GET GIVE THEM ACCESS. OR
TRAINING. SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO RESOLVE CASES- IN A REAL
TIME MANNER INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO KIND OF. GO BACK AND CHECK
FOR US OR GO BACK AND- AND DO
ADDITIONAL WORK. IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE I GUESS IN MY MIND. THAT
THOSE WHO ARE ASSIGNED TO OUR
OFFICES ARE. ABLE TO. ADDRESS
AND FIX THE CLAIMS AS THEY SEE
FIT IF IT CAN BE RESOLVED IN
THAT MANNER. AND AS A RESULT
THE BACKLOG EVEN QUICKER IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DONE- SOBER LIVING LIKE IF YOU
BACK. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CAROLYN SO TAKE THE- TAKE THE
FIRST PART OF THIS QUESTION IN
NANCY MAY WANT TO- JUMP IN- THE
HELP BUT UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION SO LET ME JUST TELL
YOU WHAT WE ARE DOING. WE HAVE
INCREASED THE HOURS THAT OUR
STAFF ARE ASSIGNED TO YOUR
STAFF. TO AND- MOVE REMOVE THE
BARRIERS FOR PAYMENT FOR THESE
CLAIMANTS AND WORK THESE
COMPLICATED CASES OFTENTIMES TO
COME GET IT SOMETIMES THEY'RE
NOT THEY JUST NEED TO BE IN
TOUCH WITH US BECAUSE THERE.
THERE ACCOUNT IS SOMETHING
CLEARLY HAS HAPPENED TO IT IS
NOT. IN THE 90% THAT IS PURELY
AUTOMATED FROM START TO FINISH
YOUR STAFF WERE CLEARLY
INVOLVED IN THE 10% OF THE
MANUAL WORK WORKS IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME INTERVENTION. SO WHAT
WE HAVE DONE IS INCREASE THE
HOURS THAT THEY ARE WORKING
THESE CASES. OKAY I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S THAT THAT WOULD
I'M TRYING TO STREAMLINE A FULL
THE PROJECT. AND SO INSTEAD OF
FOR IT. IF YOU NEED TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING AND- DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF THEY ARE
INVALUABLE- NONE OF US SAW THE
PANDEMIC COMING- BUT WE
CERTAINLY WANT ME TO DO. MORE
OF OUR PARK OKAY WELL I WOULD
JUST ADD AND TO SUGGEST THAT IF
YOU CAN GIVE THE LIAISON STORE
OFFICES- MORE ACCESS AND MORE
TRAINING TO RESOLVE SITUATIONS-
IN REAL TIME- NOT. AT THAT
MAYBE SO AND HELP HELP AND
MAYBE HELP US FACILITATE THAT
TO- THAT MAY EASE SOME STRESS
OFF OF YOU IN THE MAIL HE SOME
STRESS OFF OF US AS WELL SO-
SOMETHING THAT I HOPE THAT THAT
YOU'LL TAKE BACK INSIGNE AND
SUGGEST- AND KIND OF PONDER
OVER BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. WOULD. BE
HELPFUL I APPRECIATE THAT THE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
FONG I'LL SO SEVERAL ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED IN THE PAST WE STILL
CONTINUE TO SEE ISSUES RELATED
TO LANGUAGE COMPETENCY ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY- BEING ABLE TO
GET SOMEBODY ON THE PHONE SO
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES AND
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE REYES AND
THIS COMMITTEE AND THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN A PART OF IN OTHER
HEARINGS AS WELL- AND SO I
GUESS IT IS RATHER SURPRISING
THAT GIVEN. THE COMPLETE LACK
OF RESOURCES AND THE BACKLOG
THAT THERE IS AN AN AND AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST TO
KIND OF CLARIFY THOSE ISSUES
INCLUDING- THE CALL CENTER AND
SO. ARE THESE- DO YOU PLAN ON
AND EXCUSE ME IF I MISSED IT
EARLIER BUT DO YOU PLAN ON
ADDRESSING THE SOMETIME LATER
IN THE BUDGET ASK. MADAM CHAIR
NEED TO VARIOUS WITH EDT- SO AT
THIS TIME- WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE- REQUESTING MORE
RESOURCES. IF WE IF WE DO FIND
THAT WE NEED THEM WE CERTAINLY-
I BELIEVE WE CAN USE AND- IT'S-
THE MAY REVISE PROCESS OR THE
OCTOBER REVISED PROCESS TO
REQUEST- MORE RESOURCES- AS AS
YOU KNOW CALEB MENTIONED THAT
THE BE IT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE ARE
FEDERALLY FUNDED WE DO HAVE
AMPLE FEDERAL RESOURCES RIGHT
NOW- BUT AGAIN TO CLOSE THE
LOOP AT SOME POINT THOSE
RESOURCES WILL. DRY UP I
SUPPOSE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WAY OF SAYING IT AND WE WILL
NEED MORE RESOURCES THAT IS.
LIKELY NOT TO HAPPEN- DURING
THE PANDEMIC BUT IT LIKELY WILL
HAPPEN AFTER THE PANDEMIC AND
WE AS WE- OF COURSE DON'T WANT
TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE TWICE
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE ARE READY FOR
WHATEVER COMES NEXT- HOPEFULLY
NOT ANOTHER PANDEMIC BUT- WE
KNOW WHATEVER THAT IS THAT'S
REALLY WHEN. WE AREN'T WHAT
WHEN WE WOULD NEED TO- YOU KNOW
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES FOR
THAT NEXT THING. SO I GUESS
WHAT I'M HEARING IT MISS VERY
IS THAT YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY BUT YOU HAVE BEEN
FULLY STAFFED UP YET. WHICH
YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING.
AND SO THE WORKLOAD CONTINUES
TO BE IMPACTED BASED ON THAT
AND- OUR STAFF AND MOSTLY OUR
DISTRICT STAFF WHICH IS TASKED
WITH DEALING WITH A LOT OF THE
EDT CASES. AND MANAGING THOSE
CASES. NEEDS ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTS I WANT TO ECHO MR
FONG- YOU COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE EDT
LIAISON TO EACH. ASSEMBLY
OFFICE BECAUSE WHILE IT WORKS
SOMETIMES IN MOSTLY DOESN'T
JUST BASED ON BANDWIDTH. AND I
WOULD IMAGINE THE BANDWIDTH AND
WORKLOAD OF THE EDT LIAISON TO.
THAT'S PROBABLY BEING SHARED
AMONG MULTIPLE OFFICES. AND SO
WHOEVER THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
DON'T HAVE CAPACITY IN BAND
WITH TO DEAL WITH ALL THE CASES
THAT ARE COMING IN THROUGH THE
DISTRICT OFFICES- IN THE
CONSTITUENT CASES SO WE COULD
REALLY USE. YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THAT AND FINDING A FULL TIME
DEDICATED LIAISONS THAT CAN
ANSWER A QUESTION SO THAT WE
ARE ALSO NOT. WAITING FOR
RESPONSES AND ALSO A NEVER
NEVER ANSWERED EMAILS OR BEING
ON HOLD ON THE PHONE FOR A LONG
TIME AS WELL SINCE IT'S
ESCALATED AT THAT LEVEL. I WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS I WANNA THANK YOU
DIDI FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS FROM LAST MONTH'S
HEARING THAT WERE DUE OUT THIS
PAST FRIDAY. AND DIRECTOR SIGNS
RESPONSE IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
IT TAKES ABOUT TWO TO FOUR
WEEKS FOR IDENTIFICATION
VERIFICATION. HOWEVER NEWS
REPORTS AND CONSTITUENT
FEEDBACK HAS SHOWN THAT THIS
PROCESS CAN ACTUALLY TAKE SIX
WEEKS OR MORE AS WAS STATED
EARLIER. WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
SPEED UP THIS PROCESS OBVIOUSLY
WAITING SIX WEEKS OR MORE TO
BE. RE VERIFIED ON ID
MEANWHILE. YOU DON'T HAVE MONEY
TO FEED YOUR KIDS OR YOUR
LIVING YOU KNOW ALREADY AT ADD.
YOUR YUR AT YOUR MEANS AND
AFRAID OF BEING AN- ARTIST.
FEDERA PLAYS A MENTAL HEALTH
TOLL ON EVERYONE THAT'S
AFFECTED BY I BY THIS PANDA
ANSWER. WAITING FOR THE SAFETY
NET OF EDT TWO. SO WHAT WHAT
CAN WE DO TO SPEED UP THIS
PROCESS. CANTERBURY'S THANK
YOU- FOR THAT COMMENT WE
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW. UNDERSTAND
THE PREDICAMENT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE RE IN AND WE ARE- VERY
COGNIZANT OF THAT AND WE ARE
WORKING- TOWARD TOWARDS- THAT
AND ON ON I. D. I WILL SAY
THAT- MOST OF THE PEOPLE 90% OF
THE PEOPLE GO THROUGH ID NEED
WITHIN. A MATTER OF. A COUPLE
OF DAYS AND ARE PAID- BY- ET
DEEP WITHIN I THINK SEVEN TO
TEN DAYS IS THE AVERAGE- THOUGH
THE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET
THROUGH ID ME AS AS- YOU
POINTED OUT NOT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO. ON YOU YOU AYE
ONLINE OR ID ME- THEY WILL HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A PAPER PROCESS-
THROUGH EDT OR THEY CAN CALL
IN. AND YOU KNOW WE CAN HELP
THEM WITH THAT AND I DOES TAKE
LONGER BECAUSE IT IS NOT
AUTOMATED- WE ARE LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES TO SHORTEN THAT TIME
FRAME- AND YOU KNOW AND DO KNOW
THAT WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD THAT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. BEFORE AND FROM
CLAIMANTS BEFORE AND WE ARE
DOING OUR ABSOLUTE BEST TO-
STREAMLINE THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- ONE MORE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ISSUE AREA IS- IN BANK
OF AMERICA'S LETTER WHICH WAS
ALSO DO THIS PAST FRIDAY.
RESPONDING TO OUR QUESTIONS
THAT WERE NOT- ANSWERED IN THE
EARLIER HEARING THAT WE HAD IN
ABOUT A MONTH AGO- IT WAS
STATED THAT APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND CARDS WERE
FROZEN BY THE BANK DOES BANK OF
AMERICA CONSULTS WITH EDT WHEN
FREEZING THESE CARDS. OR DOES
EDT CONTACT THE CLAIMANT OR DO
THEY STILL NEED TO WAIT FOR A
BANK OF AMERICA LETTER- BANK OF
AMERICA WHEN THEY FREEZE THE
CARDS DATE THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT CONTACT THE CLAIMANTS.
OKAY SO DO THEY SEND THE AND I
JUST WANT CLARITY ON THIS
BECAUSE WE'VE GOTTEN SOME MIXED
INFORMATION SO WHO MAKES THE
DECISION OF FREEZING THE CARD
IS THAT BANK OF AMERICA OR IS
THAT EDT. SO BANK OF AMERICA
WILL FREEZE THE CARD WE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO. DEBIT CARDS WE
HAVE ACCESS TO WE ONLY PROVIDE
BANK OF AMERICA WITH THE FUNDS
TO SO WHAT WHAT EDT DOESN'T IS
WE CAN DO A STOP PAY. BUT BY
BANK OF AMERICA WILL FREEZE THE
CARDS. IF THEY FIND FRAUD
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW I MEAN AS
THEY HAVE SAID IN SEVERAL
HEARINGS IN THE NATION WIDE
FRAUD ISSUE AND THEY HAVE-
THEIR OWN PROCESS FEES AND
REGULATIONS THAT THEY HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH. ON A FEDERAL LEVEL.
THANK YOU I'M NOT QUITE SURE MR
IS THAT I THAT I TRULY
UNDERSTAND AND HAVE CLARITY ON
WHO MAKES THE DECISION THAT
THERE'S FRAUD. IS THE TWO
FOLDERS IT EDT MAKING A
DECISION AND THEN TELLING BANK
OF AMERICA AND IS IT ALSO BANK
OF AMERICA THROUGH THEIR SYSTEM
ALSO IDENTIFYING POTENTIAL
FRAUD SO IT'S BOTH. THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION AND YES IT IS
BOTH SO WE BOTH HAVE SO EDT HAS
A PROCESS THAT WE GO THROUGH
THE WHICH WE'VE SAID BEFORE THE
I. D. NEED THOMSON REUTERS
THERE'S AN INTERNAL FLAG THAT
WE HAVE. IF THE PERSON THE
CLAIMANT HAS PASSED THROUGH
THAT SO TO SPEAK THEN THERE IS
NO IF WE DON'T FIND FRAUD. WHEN
THE WHEN WE THEN SAY OKAY
THERE'S NO FRAUD AND THAT
PAYMENT GOES TO BANK OF AMERICA
BANK OF AMERICA SEES THINGS AS
THEY MENTIONED IN THE PAST
HEARING THAT EDT DOES NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO. LIKE TRANSACTIONAL
HISTORY FOR EXAMPLE SO IF
SOMEONE GOES TO AN ATM WE DON'T
SEE WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT SORT OF FRAUD SO THAT'S
THE FRAUD THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO. AND THEY CAN THEN FREEZE
THE CARD IF THEY FIND IN FRAUD
FOLLOWING REGULATIONS THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THAT THEY
HAVE- BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE AN INTERNATIONAL. MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR BANK. RIGHT NOW
IT CLICK CLEARLY IN THE PAST
TEN YEARS OF A GOOD PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN EQUALLY BENEFICIAL TO
BANK OF AMERICA. SO  GUESS AS
AS WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT NEXT
STEPS AND THE RENEGOTIATING THE
BANK OF AMERICA CONTRACT WITH
EDT. AM I HEARING THAT THESE
ARE POTENTIAL THINGS TO LOOK
OUT FOR IN TERMS OF WHO IS
ACTUALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
GETTING A HOLD OF THE CLAIMANT
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE ON ONE
SIDE IT'S- EDT MAKES ONE
DECISION BASED ON THE INTERNAL
PROCESSES FOR FRAUD. BANK OF
AMERICA HAVING ACCESS TO- THE
TRANSACTIONAL INFORMATION CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENT DECISION. YET
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL
CONTACT OF THE CLAIMANT THAT'S
WHEN THINGS GET A LITTLE LOOSE
IN TERMS OF WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS TO. GET A
HOLD OF THAT INDIVIDUAL. IS
THAT ACCURATE OR- THAT AND THAT
IS ACCURATE AND I AND I WOULD
SAY THAT- EDT WE DO YOU KNOW WE
ALSO HAVE TO FOLLOW DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR REGULATIONS AND THERE
IS DUE PROCESS. SO WE DO
PROVIDE NOTICE- TO CLAIMANTS
WHEN WE PUT YOU KNOW WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS ON THEIR
ACCOUNT AND WE HAVE TO PUT A
STOP PAY WE DO DO THAT- THAT IS
FROM THE ELIGIBILITY SIDE WHEN
THEY COME INTO EDT AFTER IT
LEAVES AFTER THAT. THE PAYMENT
LEAVES EDT THEN THAT IS WHEN IT
LIES WITH BANK OF AMERICA TO
GIVE NOTICE PER THEIR OWN
BANKING REGULATIONS ON WHAT
THEY WOULD DO FOR ANY PERSON
WHO HAS A BANK CARD. OKAY GOT
IT THESE ARE SOME INTERESTING
LITTLE DETAILS I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO. TAKE A REALLY CLOSE
LOOK AT AS WE FIGURE OUT NEXT
STEPS ON THE FRAUD A
CONVERSATION ON WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT PRECIADO- WE DIDN'T
GET ALL THE RESPONSES BACK FROM
BANK OF AMERICA BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY GOING TO BEING
FOLLOWING UP IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT OVERLAY WITH THE
EDT DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS OUR
NEXT STEPS FOR HOLDING. THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY CAN
BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE THANK
YOU. LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR-
ISSUE NUMBER TWO BUT BEFORE I
DO THAT I DO APOLOGIZE WE DID
NOT GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM THE ALLULOSE OFFICE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS RELATED TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAD ALAMO WITH THE
L. A. WE WERE ON THE PANEL TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC COMMENTS RELATED
TO THAT THE OVERSIGHT ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
ALLEN MISTER JIMENEZ. HI MARK
MENACE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE DONE I
AM HAPPY TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE I AS AND QUESTIONS- GREAT
LET'S DO THAT AND I KNOW THAT-
MR PEROT ACTUALLY MADE SOME
EARLY COMMENTS ON B. HE DID THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I KNOW MR
CHIU HAD ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
ON THAT WHY DON'T WE MOVE
FORWARD IN MR. PEROT CAN YOU
JUST GIVE US A BRIEF OVERVIEW
ONE MORE TIME AS WE ENTER INTO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- ONCE AGAIN
CALEB WORRELL CHIEF OF FISCAL
PROGRAMS DIVISION FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET
REQUEST. THE PROPOSAL INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. TO MAKE
THE FIRST INTEREST PAYMENT ON A
FEDERAL LOAN. THE STATE
RECEIVED AN ORDER CONTINUE
PAYING. UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. AFTER THE U. I. FUND
BECAME INSOLVENT AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC. WHEN THE STATE'S
YOU I TRUST FUND BECOMES
INSOLVENT. THE STATE IS STILL
OBLIGATED BY FEDERAL LAW. TO
PAY BENEFITS TO ELIGIBLE
WORKERS. THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
BEGINNING IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE NECESSITATING
LOANS. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN ORDER FOR THE
STATE TO KEEP UP WITH BENEFIT
PAYMENTS TO UNEMPLOYED WORKERS.
WE RECOGNIZE THEM AS THE L. A.
M. NOTES IN THERE RIGHT AFTER.
THAT THE INITIAL ESTIMATE WHICH
WAS PREDICATED ON A FAIRLY
PESSIMISTIC ECONOMIC OUTLOOK.
AND ALSO DID NOT INCLUDE RECENT
LOAN INTEREST FORGIVENESS. THAT
WAS PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE MOST- CURRENT
STIMULUS ACT. THAT WAS PASSED
IN DECEMBER. THAT THE THAT
THOSE TWO RESULTING PIECES WILL
DEFINITELY RESULT IN. THE
PAYMENT BEING LOWER COME
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHEN THAT PAYMENT BECOMES DUE-
ADDITIONALLY IT'S ALSO WORTH
NOTING. THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
COVET NINETEEN RELIEF PACKAGE
THAT'S- MAKING ITS WAY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. DOES CONTAIN
FURTHER INTEREST RELIEF.
THROUGH THE END OF AUGUST WHICH
COULD MEAN. ULTIMATELY ONE
MONTH OF INTEREST PAYMENTS. FOR
STATES IN THE FIRST YEAR
BORROWING. THE DEPARTMENT WILL
UPDATE THE ESTIMATED LOAN
INTEREST AMOUNT AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYOR VISION. AND IT
WILL BE FURTHER UPDATED BASED
ON PROPOSED BUDGET LANGUAGES
THE PAYMENT DATE GETS NEAR. IN
SEPTEMBER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT A CAN HEAR FROM
THE ADD TO. OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS THE ALEJO'S OFFICE PLEASE.
MISSILE MORE WHEN WE GO WITH
YOU. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAD ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- OUR OFFICE-
REVIEWED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IN JUST A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS TED TO BUILD ON ON
WHAT WAS JUST MENTIONED BY
MISTER WORLD ON AS HE NOTED
ABSOLUTELY THE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INTEREST
PAYMENT ESTIMATE WAS BASED ON
WHAT IS NOW OUTDATED ECONOMIC
INFORMATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
END OF DECEMBER EXTENSION AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR- YOU AYE
ENHANCEMENTS EXTENDED THE
INTEREST WAIVER ALSO AS MISTER
OR MENTION WE THINK THESE TWO
CHANGES COMBINED ARE LIKELY TO
REDUCE. INTEREST PAYMENT DUE IN
SEPTEMBER FROM FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS I'M DEFERRED. IT MAYBE
LIKELY- WITH THE PASSAGE OF A
ADDITIONAL ACTS AND CONGRESS
THAT THE WAIVER WOULD WOULD BE
PUSHED TO AUGUST- AS MISTER
HALL MENTIONED MEANING MAYBE
JUST ONE MONTH OF INTEREST TO
YOU I WE WON'T KNOW THAT UNTIL
SOMETIME BUT WHAT UPDATE. FOR
THE MAY REVISION. THE ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT THAT WE WANT
TO BRING UP HERE IS THAT
FEDERAL LAW DOES. ALLOW A
PROVISION UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND ASSENS
DURING. ERA INSTANCES OF
ELEVATED UNEMPLOYMENT I ALLOWS
THE STATE TO DEFER PORTION OF
THEIR INTEREST PAYMENTS INTO
FUTURE YEARS- SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE STATE. IS AS WE BELIEVE
ELIGIBLE TO THE FIRST THREE
QUARTERS OF THIS YEAR'S
INTEREST PAYMENTS INTO THE
FUTURE ON PAYING ONE QUARTER IN
IN EACH OF THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. AND IMPORTANTLY INTEREST
ON THIS DEFERRAL- WOULD NOT
ITSELF ACCRUE INTEREST I'M SO
THERE'S NO FISCAL PENALTY PER
SE- TO DIFFERING THIS YEAR'S
INTEREST PAYMENT- WE RECOMMEND
THAT. AT THIS POINT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE SMALLER
ESTIMATE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
INTEREST PAYMENT AND ALSO TAKE
ACTION TO- AVAIL ITSELF OF THE
DEFERRAL. I WHICH WOULD REDUCE
THE UPCOMING SEPTEMBER INTEREST
PAYMENT- FROM FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION IN TOTAL TO
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AS WE ESTIMATE. I'M
FINALLY AGAIN ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THESE NUMBERS WILL ALL BE
REVISED BOTH BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR OFFICE
AS PART OF THE MAY REVISION-
BUT IT'S HELPFUL IN OUR VIEW TO
GET A SENSE OF. WHERE THE SCOPE
OF THIS INTEREST PAYMENT IS AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER JIMENEZ. HI
MARK MINNESOTA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- JUST. WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT WE WILL BE
PROVIDING THESE ESTIMATES IN
THE MAY REVISED- WE'RE ALSO
HAPPY TO WORK WELL WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR STAFF AND ALL THE-
IT'S BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
PROPOSALS THAT- THE LTO JUST
PRESENTED- IT DIDN'T TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE FOR YOU ON
AND DEVELOP THE BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS TALKING MAYBE FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO NOW TO MEMER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS- MISTER TO
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM
MEDICARE THANK YOU AND-
APPRECIATE THE BACKGROUND ON
THIS ITEM- I'VE BEEN DIGGING IN
A LITTLE BIT TOO THIS IS NOT A
TOPIC WE DISCUSSED I THINK IN
THE SUB COMMITTEE- AND- MIGHT
MY HEADLINE FOR THIS PORTION
THE CONVERSATION COULD BE. OUT
OF THE FRYING PAN INTO THE FIRE
AND BY THAT I MEAN WE HAVE
SPENT THE BETTER PART OF THIS
YEAR ON. THE VERY INTENSE AND
IMMEDIATE CRISES IMPACTING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS BUT WE
ARE WORKING WITH A U. Y. SYSTEM
THAT UP I'M CONCERNED IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN- THE
COMMITTEE REPORT. ALLUDES TO
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA'S.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND BECAME INSOLVENT SINCE
PRIOR TO JUNE TWENTY TWENTY AND
IS POJECTED TO REMAIN SOLVENT
THROUGH AT LEAST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND IT LAYS OUT WHAT ARE
THE PENALTIES TO THE STATE TO
THE TUNES OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IF WE- DO NOT PAY THESE
INTEREST PAYMENTS WHICH ARE
SUBSTANTIAL. NOT SURE IF YOU
HAD A CHANCE TO SEE THE OP ED
THIS WEEK THAT WAS PUBLISHED BY
THE DIRECTOR OF THE STANFORD
INSTITUTE OF ECONOMIC POLICY
RESEARCH. BUT WHAT HE LAYS OUT
AND I'LL JUST. MENTION THIS IS
A YEAR AGO THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR RELEASED
ITS ANNUAL SOLVENCY REPORT OF
STATE YOU Y. PROGRAMS AND
RANKED CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM
DEAD LAST. AMONG ALL FIFTY
STATES NOW CALIFORNIA'S YOU AYE
PROGRAM IS NINETEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT. AND THE OP ED
LAYS OUT THE FACT THAT THIS IS
A FUNCTION OF THE FACT THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS INCREDIBLY
REGRESSIVE. IS FUNDED AT TWO
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE LEVELS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY HURTS LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND SO MY QUESTION I
APPRECIATE WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE CRISIS I
WANT TO ASK. THE E. D.
LEADERSHIP WHAT IS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE NEED FOR
LONG TERM REFORM OF THE SYSTEM
WHERE'S YOUR THINKING ON THIS
BECAUSE- THE IDEA THAT- THAT-
MADAM CHAIR AND I AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO KEEP VOTING ON
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INTEREST PAYMENTS. ON
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
GRAPPLING WITH- MAKES SENSE TO
ME AND YOU KNOW I THINK IT WAS
THIS VERY ISSUE SAID- WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO FIX THE
SYSTEM FOR THE LONG HAUL AND IT
SEEMS TO ME WE ARE NOT. WE
HAVEN'T EVEN HAD A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE LONG TERM. FACING ARE
YOU AYE SYSTEMS A LOT BUT SOME
COMMENT ON ON THAT. I MEAN.
NUMBER EIGHTY VARIOUS WITH EDT-
YOUR COMMENTS ARE VERY WELL
TAKEN- YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL- RIGHT NOW TO FIX THAT
BUT WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION. MOVING FORWARD ON
THAT. BOB WHAT I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO
MANY THINGS WE NEED TO DO TO
FIX HE D. AT THIS MOMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY. ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
ARE CONSTITUENTS SHUTTING DOWN
FRAUD THESE ARE TWO THINGS WE
NEED TO DO NOW. BUT IF IT IS
POSSIBLE FOR US TO HAVE
ANOTHER- SIMULTANEOUS
CONVERSATION- AGAIN PAIN HALF
BILLION DOLLAR INTEREST
PAYMENTS IS NOT PRETTY I I'M
SURE ALL OF US IN THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE COULD THINK ABOUT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE
COULD SPEND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS A SITUATION THAT
PREDATED ALL OF US- BUT I THINK
THAT THERE ARE PRETTY GOOD FROM
WHAT I MIGHT EARLY
CONVERSATIONS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES. FROM LATE.
WELL AS FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS IS I THINK
THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD. STABILIZE THE SYSTEM
FOR THE LONG HAUL AND I'D BE
INTERESTED IN HAVING A
CONVERSATION SIMULATOR- IF NOT
YOU KNOW THIS MONTH THEN IN THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS THIS YEAR-
AND I'LL JUST ASK THAT EDT
LEADERSHIP WHENEVER YOU WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THIS. I'D LIKE TO AS
WELL. I APPECIATE THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS.
I THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
CHAIR- ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER TO APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK A WE ALL WANT TO HAVE
SOLUTIONS TO THE MOST PRESSING
ISSUES WITH EDT ONE OF THEM
BEING THE SYSTEM THAT IS
INCREDIBLY. FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND ANTIQUATED AND
SHOULD PROBABLY AT THIS POINT
SIMPLY BE REPLACED. AND WE WILL
GET TO THAT WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- FOR THAT
COMES UP BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT- INTERESTED IN TRYING
TO FIX AND IND A SOLUTION FOR.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
EVERYONE. AND I DID I DID SAY
EARLIER THAT WE WERE GONNA. I
TRIED TO GO THROUGH OUR NINE
ISSUES- WITH WITH THE
APPROPRIATE TIME SO WE ARE IN
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THIS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS AND
HIGHER WAGES WE HAVE TIM RAINY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD MICHAEL CABLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PLUMBING
TRAINING PANEL MISTER CHAZ
ALAMO WITH ELLY ELLS OFFICE AS
WELL AS MISTER JIMENEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET'S
BEGIN ON ISSUE NUMBER THREE
MYSTERY. THANK YOU CORREO I
HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY WE
CAN HEAR YOU TO BRING NINE.
THANK YOU I TEN RAINY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD. I
WAS HOPING I COULD GO THROUGH I
JUST A BRIEF INTRODUCTION OF
THE NEW DEPARTMENT. HOWEVER THE
WHAT AT WHAT WE'RE DOING- A
LITTLE BIT ON THE WHY WE'RE
CREATING A NEW DEPARTMENT- AND
THEN FINALLY THE HOUSE. JUST A
BIT OF INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STEPS TAKEN TO MOVE FORWARD-
AND THEN OF COURSE- WOULD LOVE
TO. TAKE QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE
RESPONSES- MICHAEL CABLE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL IS HERE AS WELL-
TO FIELD QUESTIONS. WHAT LET'S
PROPOSAL- WHAT SCHOOL. CENTER
LAST YEAR AT THE GOVERNOR MADE
THIS PROPOSAL YEAR. RAINING
JUST BE CLEAR YEAR ON THE PHONE
NOT ON CAMERA. I AM ON CAMERA
ACTUALLY- WE CAN ASSURE YOU
IT'S ALL DARK- WE CAN HEAR YOU
JUST FINE BUT WE CAN'T SEE YOU-
THERE YOU GO OKAY OKAY WE-
BUDGET IN MY CAMERA- SO AS I
WAS SAYING- THE WHITE OF THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT IT'S THE SAME
PROPOSALS LAST YEAR THE
GOVERNOR PRESENTED- IT IS TO
CONSOLIDATE FOR WORKFORCE
ENTITIES. WITHIN THE LABOR
AGENCY INTO A SINGLE WORK FORCE
DEPARTMENT- THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD ANY
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL- COME
WHOLE CLOTH INTO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT THAT THE DIVISION
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS IS
PULLED FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRY RELATIONS- ARE IN THE
WORKFORCE SERVICES BRANCH IS
PULLED FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT INTO THE
NEW DEPARTMENT SO IT IS A TWO
STEP PROCESS- THE STATUTORY
CHANGES ARE THIS YEAR. ASIDES
pRELATED TO THE FOUR ENTITIES
INTO A NEW DIVISION SIX OF THE
LABOR CODE WHICH IS BEFORE YOU
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- THAT
THE NEXT STEP IS THE BUDGET
PROCESS UP NEXT YEAR BY THE
CHANGES IN BUDGET FOR NEXT
YEAR- WHERE THE NEW DEPARTMENT
WILL SUBMIT A BCP. FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
REQUESTING THE BOOK OF. IT ENDS
UP BEING. D. I. R. SO COURSE
THE VICIOUS HERE. WILL IT MEANS
THE WORLD BURKE OF UP TO AND UP
THE DEPARTMENT WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY. HI VERY QUICKLY UP TO
REACH FOR THAT TELEVISION THE
FIRST IS. FOLLOW FONG WORKS
RIGHT IT WORKS FUNCTIONS THE
DEPART MENT WITHIN DEPARTMENT
MISTER RANEY. I'M GONNA OF FOR
A MOMENT- IT SEEM LIKE YOU'RE
YOU'RE VIDEOS IS AN- YOUR AUTO.
WHY DON'T WE TURN OFF YOUR YOUR
CAMERA JUST SO THAT WE CAN HEAR
YOU. SURE LET'S TRY AGAIN WE
LOST YOU FOR LIKE THIRTY
SECONDS. MY APOLOGIES AGAIN-
TECHNOLOGY IF YOUR FRIEND AND
YOUR WORST ENEMY SOMETIMES. I
OKAY START AGAIN I'M THE Y. IT
THAT FORGIVE ME- TO TWO MAIN
REASONS THE FIRST IS FORM
SHOULD FOLLOW FUNCTION- THE
WORKFORCE SERVICES THE BRANCH
IS INSIDE AN APARTMENT AS WE
TALKED ABOUT A GREAT DEAL-
TODAY. IT'S PART WITH A PRIMARY
FOCUS ON BENEFITS AND TAXATION
INCLUDING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DIVISION
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS IS A
WORK FORCE FUNCTION WITHIN A
DEPARTMENT WHOSE PRIMARY FOCUS
IS LABOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. SO
THEY CONSOLIDATED WORKFORCE
DEPARTMENT WILL FOCUS ON
WORKFORCE INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIPS
AND REGIONAL TALENT DEVELOPMENT
PATHWAYS TO QUALITY JOBS EQUITY
IN INCOME ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
WHO MOST NEED GOOD JOBS AND
FORCE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WE
FEEL LIKE THIS FOCUS ON
WORKFORCE IS AS URGENT AS
ANYTHING WE COULD BE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. THE SECOND IS- IS
FOR SYSTEM ALIGNMENT TO GET
GREATER IMPACT THROUGH SCALE A
SCALE AND IMPACT- THE WORK. FOR
SERVICES. OUT WHAT PRESERVES
THE JOURNAL ARE ARE DELIVERED
LOW- AND IF ACROSS MULTIPLE
AGENTS. AND ENTITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL I IN EACH OF THESE
FUNDING STREAMS COME FROM
DEPARTMENTS IN SACRAMENTO THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT MAJOR MISSIONS
IN DIFFERENT PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS INSIDER. SO IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT. FOR COMPANIES
AND WORKERS TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE SYSTEM. SO
WE'RE CREATING THIS CALL
COMPLEXITY UP BY THE FACT THAT
THESE FUNCTIONS ARE MINISTERED
THROUGH MULTIPLE AGENCIES IN
SACRAMENTO AND THEN GO DOWN TO
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. ALSO HAVE DIFFERENT
SERVICE CULTURES REQUIREMENTS
DATA. COLLECTION PROCESSES IT'S
STATURE. THE END OF THE DAY.
THE PEOPLE WERE MOST TRYING TO
SERVE. OUR FINDING THE SYSTEM-
THIS PATCHWORK THAT VERY
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE- THE FIX.
CAN'T BE JUST AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WE SPENT. MANY YEARS MICE
IN- UPGRADE. WILL WORKFORCE PER.
AT TO BE MORE ALIGNED- SO IT SO
THAT THE SYSTEM IS LESS
COMPLEX. AND MORE NAVIGABLE. HE
HE THE FACT IS WE CAN'T FIX
THIS JUST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
I SAID WE CREATE THE CONDITIONS
FOR THIS- THIS PATCHWORK IN
SACRAMENTO AND WASHINGTON DC-
SO. IN FACT THIS PURPOSE OF
MAKING IT MORE NAVIGABLE FOR
WORKERS WHO MOST NEED SERVICES
AND FOR COMPANIES IS IT I THINK
EXACTLY WHY. THE NEW DEPARTMENT
IS SUPPORTED BY. BOTH LABOR AND
BUSINESS WE HAVE SEVERAL
LETTERS I THINK THAT HAVE COME
INTO THE COMMITTEE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THAT MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS THE CAL CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION- AND TWELVE OR
THIRTEEN LETTERS. OF SUPPORT
HAVE COMIC COME IN BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT OF THE
SYSTEM ON'T LOCAL WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES AND HOW CAN BE
IMPROVED THROUGH THIS
STREAMLINING. THAT WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING THE STATE LEVEL- OR
NOT COMPLETELY THERE EVEN IF
WHEN WE OUR IF WE- CONSOLIDATE
THESE. THESE ENTITIES INSIDE
THE LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY THERE STILL ARE AT LEAST
THIRTY WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. THIS
IS FROM LA- THIRTY WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THIRTEEN DIFFERENT STATE
DEPARTMENTS. AND SEVEN AGENCIES
IN SACRAMENTO SO THERE'S A LOT
OF ROOM FOR CONTINUED MR
MISALIGNMENT FRAGMENTATION THAT
CONSUMES. UP PRECIOUS TIME AND
RESOURCES FOR JOB SEEKERS WHO
DON'T HAVE TIME AND RESOURCES.
SO IS A SAID THE CONSOLIDATION
WITHIN THE LABOR AGENCY. IT IS
A SIGNIFICANT FIRSTSTEP. TO
MAKE IN A SYSTEM. THAT IS- IS
WORKING BETTER FOR WORKING
PEOPLE IN THE STATE I BELIEVE
IT'S THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT-
AND THEY QUICKLY ON THE HOUSE
AND THEN ALL. OF A HAND IT.
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE HE'S
GOTTEN IT YET I WILL JUST ASK
THAT YOU WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE. OF COURSE. THE HOW IS
ALREADY IN THE PROCESS OF
ALIGNING THE FOUR ENTITIES- AND
WE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
OUTLINING ASTRUCTURE FOR NEW
NEW DEPARTMENT WERE FOLLOWING
THE GULF OPS MANUAL FOR THIS
WORK. I HAVE NINE WORK GROUPS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ACTIVE FOR THE-
FOR THE LAST YEAR- BETTER.
GOING DEEP INSIDE THE
ORGANIZATIONS ENGAGING STAFF
WE'VE GOT MORE GROUPS ON NINETY
SIX YLIDES FISCAL PERSONNEL
SECTOR. AND AN ACTING
LEADERSHIP THAT REPRESENTS THE
EXISTING ENTITIES. GUIDING THIS
WORK THAT THE CURRENT DIRECTORS
OF THE FOUR ENTITIES. AND IN
THE PROPOSAL IS A NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WOULD BE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND CONFIRMED BY THE
SENATE- THAT PERSON WILL TAKE
OVER LEADERSHIP AND THEN A NEW
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR. WILL BE
APPOINTED AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT. MR CABLE.
YES MY CABLE. TRANSALPINA AND I
THINK TIM HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT
JOB IN AND LAYING ABOUT PERHAPS
THE ONLY THING THAT I WOULD ADD
SINCE MY FOCUS HAS BEEN ON THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS TO
JUST POINT OUT THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH HAPPENS
BASICALLY HE TAKING SINCE WE
HAVE THESE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND DIFFERENT
PORTIONS OF EITHER THE U. I.
CHO TO THE LABOR CODE IT'S
ESSENTIALLY A LIFT AND A DROP
INTO A NEW DIVISION SIX SO THE
ONE ITEM THAT I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THERE REALLY IS.
NO SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
LEGISLATION IT'S MUCH MORE
UPBEAT MOVEMENT. AND ALIGNMENT
WITHIN THE LABOR. THANK YOU MR
CABLE MR ALAMO. JAZUSAMO WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- THREE BRIEF POINTS WE
WE'D LIKE TO POINT OUT WITH
REGARD TO- THE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE A NEW DEPARTMENT- IN THE
FIRST- WE POINT OUT IN A
ANALYSIS WE PUBLISHED TWO WEEKS
AGO THAT THE STATE'S EXISTING
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY PERFORMS MANY OF THE
COORDINATED FUNCTIONS THAT ARE%
PROPOSED FOR THE NEW DEPARTMENT
ITSELF- THE- LABOR AGENCY WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO AND
I'M- QUOTING- ANELLI- REPORTED
THAT TIME THE AGENCY WAS
CREATED TO FIRST. IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ACCESS TO
SERVICES ELIMINATE PROGRAM
DUPLICATION ENERGY COST
EFFECTIVENESS- ACCORDING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
BETTER JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES-
WOOD- CONSOLIDATE ENTITIES TO
IMPROVE EQUITY FOR WORK FIRST
PARTICIPANTS. PROVIDE
EFFICIENCY. AND ENHANCE
CUSTOMER SERVICE- AND SO AS YOU
CAN SEE IN AND IN OUR VIEW THIS
QUITE A BIT OF OVERLAP IN THESE
TWO MISSIONS AND ACHIEVING THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT- SEEMS AT THIS POINT
WELL WITHIN THE ORIGINAL AND
ONGOING RESPONSIBILITIES OF
LABOR AGENCY ITSELF WHICH
OVERSEES EACH OF THE ENTITIES
PROPOSE FOR CONSOLIDATION. ON
THE SECOND POINT IS ALSO
RELATED TO SERVE BREAD AND
BUTTER PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION
AND THAT'S THAT. AT LEAST TO
DATE ARE A CLEAR PROBLEM WITH
THE EXISTING STRUCTURE HAS NOT
BEEN IDENTIFIED- AND SO FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S DIFFICULT TO JUDGE THE
PROPOSAL WITHOUT KNOWING
EXACTLY WHAT THE- PROBLEM IS
INTENDED TO BE SOLVED- IT ALSO
WOULD MAKE SETTING
ACCOUNTABILITY GOALS FOR THE
FUTURE DIFFICULT FOR ASSESSING.
HOW THE NEW DEPARTMENT IS
PERFORMING IN THE FUTURE OUT
RATHER DIFFICULT WITHOUT HAVING
A VERY SOLID SENSE AT THIS
POINT WHAT THE PROBLEM IS TO BE
SOLVED. AND THE THIRD ISSUE
THAT WE RAISED IS- FAR AWAY THE
MOST IMPORTANT IN OUR VIEW AND
THAT'S SIMPLY RELATED TO TIMING
WHICH THE PANDEMIC- THAT
PROPOSED REORGANIZATION WHICH
SHIFT. SIXTEEN HUNDRED STAFF
FROM ED'S WORKFORCE SERVICES
BRANCH- TO THE NEW DEPARTMENTS-
AT A TIME WHEN AS AS WE ALL
KNOW AND HAVE DISCUSSED. THIS
AFTERNOON EDT IS STRUGGLING TO
HANDLE ITS WORKLOAD RELATED TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE I'LL
POINT OUT. THE WORK FOR
SERVICES STAFF CURRENTLY ARE
NOT WORKING ON DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS ADMINISTERING YOU
WIPE BENEFITS. C. WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DEDICATE SOME
RESOURCES AND ATTENTION. TO THE
COMPLEX REORGANIZATION- OF THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT AT A TIME WHEN-
THOSE EFFORTS. HAVE OBVIOUSLY
BEEN FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE
EDT YOU AYE BACKLOG AND SO IN
OUR VIEW MOVING FORWARD WITH
THAT DEPARTMENTAL
REORGANIZATION NOW WHILE THE
STATE IS IN THE MIDST. OF THIS
CRISIS- POSES SERIOUS REST TOO
EDIE'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
ONGOING BACKLOG- AND CONTINUE
MAKING- TIMELY BENEFIT PAYMENTS
FOR YOU AYE RECIPIENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER JIMENEZ. BY MARK MINUTES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST WANTED TO DRIVE A COUPLE
OF POINTS- YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HAS
CREATED ALL WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
IN VARIOUS ENTITIES IN RESPONSE
TO SPECIFIC NEEDS AND AVAILABLE
FUNDING I'M THIS HAS RESULTED
IN IN A FRAGMENTED BURKE OR
SYSTEM AND THIS REORGANIZATION
IS INTENDED TO BETTER ALIGN- A
LINE DATA POLICY PROGRAM
ANALYSIS WITH THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AND TO CREATE A GREATER ABILITY
TO DEVELOP AND DEPLOY A NEW AND
INNOVATIVE INITIATIVES THAT THE
QUESTION WILL BE EFFECTIVE
BEING- AS WELL AS WE- LOOK
TOWARDS THE QUICK RECOVERY OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY FALLING THE
PANDEMIC I'M I'M HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THOUGHT OF THIS PROPOSAL. IF
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND GO
TO THE MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
THANK QUESTIONS LUCKY. YES MR
ALAMO INDICATED- AS THE
PROPOSED DEPARTMENT OF BETTER
JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES BUT IT
REALLY DOES NOT READ YOUR
DIRECT E. D. STAFF DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO YOU WHY BUT
WOULDN'T MOVING I'D THE NUMBER
I'VE BEEN GIVEN IS ONE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. STAFF
FROM FIFTEEN PROGRAMS A DVD
WHEN IT HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON WORK LOADER SUPERMAJORITY
TIME RELATED TO THESE YOU LIFE
PROBLEMS. I CHEN RAINY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THE WORK OF
PLANNING AND DESIGNING AND
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP- OVER THE
PROCESS FOR THE NEW DEPARTMENT-
IS TAKEN ON BY THE LEADERS OF
THE FOUR ENTITIES THAT AFFECTED
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR DEEP- THE
WORKER SERVICES BRANCH OF
EATING AND THE DIVISION
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS OF THE
I. R. SO THIS. SHOULDN'T AND IT
AND IT HASN'T. CAN SIGNIFICANT
ENERGY AND RESOURCES AWAY FROM
EATING- THE INTENTION IS TO
FOCUS ON THE WORK FORCE PEACE.
MOVE IT OVER TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT SO THAT WORKFORCE
GETS MORE- GETS MORE ATTENTION.
OKAY THAT I FIND THAT TO BE
PERPLEXING BUT- I MEAN IT WAS
JUST DESCRIBED AS A LEFT IN THE
DROP. AND THAT'S A PRETTY BIG
LEFT ALMOST FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STAFF FROM FIFTY PROGRAMS FROM
AN AGENCY THAT'S ALREADY
HAVING. IMMENSE PROBLEMS TO SAY
THE LEAST AND DELIVERING
SERVICES AND I CAN'T TO SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MISTER
LUCKY FAIR COMMENT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS IS WHILE I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DISRUPTION
WITH EDT AS WE'VE HEARD IN THE
LAST- TO ISSUE AREAS AND
VARIOUS DIFFERENT HEARINGS. NOT
JUST IN THIS ONE BUT IN OTHERS.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DISRUPTION WITH EDT IN THE
LABOR AGENCY IS IT APPROPRIATE
FOR THE LABOR AGENCY TO SHIFT
FOCUS AWAY FROM RESOLVING
EDIE'S CHALLENGES AT THIS TIME.
HI THIS IS JIM RAINY CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD- WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT DOES
SHIFT FOCUS IN FACT IT'S REALLY
THE ROLE. AS A MISTER ALMA
POINTED OUT THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON THE ALIGNMENT OF
WORK FOR SERVICES AND PROGRAMS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS THIS IS
THE NEXT STEP A BIG STEP OF OLD
ONE. TO ALIGN THOSE SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS FOR THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA- BEEN IMPACTED BY
CODE ON THE GROUND- IT AND-
NEED SERVICES TO GET BACK TO
WORK WHAT A MOVING TO BETTER
JOBS. SO I THINK THERE'S AND
THERE'S- AN IMPORTANT URGENCY
AROUND DOING THIS. AND I
BELIEVE. AND WE BELIEVE- IN THE
LABOR AGENCY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT NOW IS THE TIME. TO
MAKE THIS MOVE. AND WE WILL BE.
OUT AT THE VERY CAREFUL. NOT TO
PULL NECESSARY FOCUS AWAY FROM
STRENGTHENING EDIE'S WORK. ON
PROVIDING BENEFITS THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR OF
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THAT WE
RAISED IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
ANOTHER HEARINGS AS WELL HAS
BEEN JUST THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LABOR AGENCY. WE MAY
POTENTIALLY BE LOSING OUR
SECRETARY OF LABOR. READING OF
VACANCY WE HAVE A VACANCY IN
THE UNDERSECRETARY OF LABOR WE
HAVE BACON SEASON VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT. A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR POSITIONS WITHIN THE
AGENCY ITSELF. AND SO WHO WILL.
WHO WILL ACTUALLY BE IN CHARGE.
THIS IS TOO MANY AT CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD- I
WOULD BE LYING IF I SAID I
WASN'T SAD THAT SECRETARIES WHO.
WHAT WAS GOING TO- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR- SHE'S BEEN AN AMAZING-
FORCE. IN DOING SO MANY GREAT
THINGS IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
LABOR AGENCY FOR WORKFORCE IN
PARTICULAR DRIVING THIS AGENDA
AROUND HIGH ROAD THAT IS REALLY
DEFINING THE WORK OF THE NEW-DEPARTMENT. THE DAY TO DAY
WORK- IS WILL STILL BE CARRIED
ON AS I SAID- BY THE- THE
LEADERS OF THE EXISTING
ENTITIES THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
THE CONSOLIDATION OF THE
PROGRAMS- IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE PROCESS THAT WE INITIATED.
OVER A YEAR AGO- GOES DEEP
INSIDE OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS-
SO. THE INTENTION- AROUND HIGH
ROAD FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIS
DEPARTMENT. EXECUTIVE RELIED
ONE LEADER IN FACT IT'S REALLY
BUILT IN A TO THE PROCESS AND
IN ALL THE STAFF INVOLVED OR
DRIVING THAT WILL CONTINUE NO I
UNDERSTAND. WHO WILL ACTUALLY
OVER THE TRANSITION AND HOW
LONG WILL IT TAKE. IF THE
TRANSITIONAL HAPPEN OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT YEAR UNTIL
WE PRESENT AT B. C. P. BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE. OPPORTUNITY
TWENTY THREE- SO THAT THE
LEADERSHIP IS GONNA BE AGAIN
PROVIDED BY THAT THE DIRECTORS
OF THE EXISTING DEPARTMENTS IN
ADDITION TO THE NEW LABOR
SECRETARY WHEN. I WHEN THAT
PERSON IS APPOINTED- AND AS I
SAID BEFORE. IN THE PROPOSAL.
IS- AT THE A NEW POSITION
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT. THAT WOULD BE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR-
HOPEFULLY SOON AS POSSIBLE IS
THIS LONG SINCE THIS PROCESS
MOVES QUICKLY- AND THEN
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE. AND
THEN IT CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WILL ALSO BE HIRED. TO HELP
PROVIDE THAT LEADERSHIP SO THEY
CAN DISTINCT. LEADERSHIP BUT
THEN REPORT TO THAT. NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. OKAY SO BOTH
POSITIONS ARE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR JUST LIKE THE
SECRETARY OF LABOR IS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AS WELL AS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF LABOR IS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR JUST
LIKE. DEPUTY DIRECTORS ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY VACANT. WITHIN THE
AGENCY. I JUST I HATE TO-
BELABOR THE POINT BUT IT'S
JUST. IT'S A IT'S A LITTLE- HI
I'M LOOKING FOR A BETTER WORD
JUST IT'S KIND OF EXHAUSTING TO
THINK ABOUT CREATING NEW
DEPARTMENTS WHEN WE HAVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT STAB SO MANY
VACANCIES AND WE HAVE YET TO
REALLY FIGURE OUT. HOW DO WE
MANAGE AN EDT SYSTEM. WITH THE
POTENTIAL TRANSFER OF WHATMR
LACKEY STATED CLOSE TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. EMPLOYEES BEING
SHIFTED TO A NEW DEPARTMENT
WELL WE JUST HEARD EDT SAY THAT
WHILE THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES
ARE NOT FULLY STAFFED UP. TO
ACTUALLY MANAGE THE CURRENT
WORKLOAD AS ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES HAVE
BECOME. EDT CLAIM ADJUSTERS AS
WELL SO I PUT THAT OUT TO YOU
IN TERMS OF THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH. HOW DO WE
CREATE NEW DEPARTMENTS THAT
WILL OVERSEE THINGS THAT ARE OF
VALUE AND THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
WELL WE HAVE DEPARTMENTS THAT
CURRENTLY DON'T FUNCTION. SO. I
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JIM RAINEY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD- AGAIN THE
WITH THE INTENTION HERE IS TO
PULL THE WORK FORCE FUNCTIONS
OUT OF EDT ARE SO THAT HE CAN
BETTER FOCUS ITS LEADERSHIP. ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
OTHER BENEFITS PROGRAMS THAT
YOU NEED THE OVERSEAS- AND AT
THE SAME TIME GET THE KIND OF
FOCUS THAT WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
THAT THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
NEED. FOR RECOVERY. SO THE WAY
WE SEE IT THE WAY WE'RE
APPROACHING IT IS NOT TO TAKE
AWAY FROM YOU NEEDED BUT
ACTUALLY HELP FOCUS AGAIN ON
ITS CORE MISSION. WHILE ALSO
FOCUSING MORE INTENTLY ON THE
WORK FOR SIDE OF THE HOUSE.
THAT WOULD BEGIN WITH GETTING
PEOPLE ACCESS TO SERVICES
REDUCING THE COMPLEXITY OUT
THERE IN THE FIELD- IT IS- IS
VERY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. BUT
IT'S ALSO GONNA BE IMPORTANT
I'M GOING. THANK YOU FOR THAT
NOW I AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. JUST
THAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
PROPOSALS ON YOU DEPARTMENTS
WITH A LACK OF DETAILS AND LACK
OF DIRECTION IT'S JUST MAKES IT
DIFFICULT. THAT WHILE WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH REAL ISSUES
RELATED TO. COVERT NINETEEN AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS AND REALLY
HELPING- ARE ARE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE THEIR
BENEFITS IT SEEMS- HOW DO WE-
HOW DO WE CONSCIOUSLY MOVE
FORWARD WITH OPENING ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT THAT STILL WILL
LACK- THE LEADERSHIP NECESSARY
TO MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL WHILE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT. WHAT'S
NEEDED AND IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
FUNDING AND PROVIDING RESOURCES
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
COMPLICATIONS MOVING FORWARD
THOSE ARE JUST IDEAS THAT I
WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF. HOW DO WE
LAY OUT THE PROPER FOUNDATION
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL
VERSUS CREATING MORE. OF MORE
OF THE BUREAUCRATIC TYPE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH NO ONE
KNOWS WHERE TO GO AND THERE'S
NO- NO ONE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
TRANSPARENCY PIECES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS. SO DOES SOME FINAL
SOMEFINAL THOUGHTS BUT IF NO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
I'M SORRY DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT. THIS IS MY
CABLE WITH THE TV I JUST
THOUGHT PERHAPS I COULD ADD A
COUPLE COMMENTS- IF WHAT I WAS
HEARING WAS A LOT OF STRUGGLE
REGARDING THE LOGISTICS FOR
THIS ALIGNMENT. AND WHAT I
WANTED TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS NOT HAPHAZARD WERE
RESPECTFULLY FOLLOWING PREVIOUS
EXAMPLES UTILIZING THE CUP OPS
MANUAL FOR STANDING UP A NEW
ENTITY. I THINK WHAT I'M
HEARING NOW IS. PERHAPS A
LITTLE BIT OF THE
MISUNDERSTANDING IN THAT. WE
ARE CURRENTLY IT IS SOMEWHAT OF
A DECENTRALIZED TYPE OF PROCESS
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW IN A
TRANSITION. WHAT WE'RE
UTILIZING THESE WORK GROUPS WE
HAVE A SERIES OF VERY DETAILED
WORK GROUPS. AND THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE ARE PUSHING A LOT
OF THESE ISSUES AND LOOKING AT.
AND WHAT TIM WAS POINTING OUT
IS WHEN WE GET. THE BILL
LANGUAGE APPROVED AND WE COULD
STAND UP THAT THE APPOINTMENTS
WOULD TAKE PLACE AND THEN THERE
WOULD BE MORE OF. A PERSONNEL.
GUARDING TRANSITION. BUT I
THINK WHAT WERE HIT STRUGGLE
WITH IS WHY TAKING. NOW I THINK
WHAT WAS MISSING FROM THE
CONVERSATION. IS THIS
DECENTRALIZED.PROCESS
UTILIZING WORK GROUPS WHICH IS
FALLING BACK UP OFF. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER CABLE I THINK
WHAT WE'RE SEEN ESPECIALLY AMID
THE PANDEMIC IS A CONVERSATION
AROUND. LEADERSHIP AND A
CONVERSATION OF DIRECTORS AND
STAFF THAT ARE IN IT T WIN FOR
THE LONG TERM. THESE ARE NOT
POSITIONS THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY IN TERMS OF JUST BEING
HERE FOR A COUPLE OF MONTHS OF
A YEAR SO THIS IS. THIS
REQUIRES A AND LONG TERM
STRATEGY IN A LONG TERM GAIN.
AND SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW
THE DEPARTMENT WILL FUNCTION.
AND HOW WE GET TO THE WIN THAT
IS NECESSARY TO CREATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT ACTUALLY ASSIST
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE IN. URBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
WE'RE GONNA METALLURGIC WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA MOVE FORWARD TO
THE NEXT A ISSUE AREA THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER FOR LABOR LAW
IMPLEMENTATION AND
INTERPRETATION WORKLOAD OUR
PANELISTS TODAY INCLUDE- MARK-
POLLUTANT WITH THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
MISTER CHAZ ALAMO IN LA- AND
MISTER JIMENEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET'S
BEGIN MISTER. OF POLLUTANTS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
OMINOUS MARC POLLUTANT ON THE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE LABOR
AGENCY- I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND FOR THE PANEL'S
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. ALSO WANTED TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR
SUMMARIZING- KIND OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL ITSELF. HI MY COMMENTS
WILL BE VERY SHORT- LEAVING
OPEN MOST OF MY TIME OR MOST OF
THE TIME TODAY FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT- COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE- AS A STAFF INDICATED THAT
SOME READ THE LEAK OR AGENCY
LEADS- IT'S UNITS ON
IMPLEMENTING AND INTERPRETING
LAWS WITHIN ITS JURISDICTION
ESPECIALLY THOSE. THAT ARE
ENFORCED ACROSS SEVERAL AND-
BISPECIFIC PROPOSAL. SEEKS
ADDITIONAL PERMANENT RESOURCES
AT WITHIN THE LABOR AGENCY
LEGAL UNIT TO FOCUS ON THOSE
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES. WITH
THOSE ACTIVITIES INCLUDE OUR
PUBLIC OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
SO THOSE INCLUDE ON SENDING. A
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
OTHER PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
MATERIAL OUTREACH MATERIAL
EDUCATIONAL MATERIAL FOR THE
PUBLIC- ANOTHER IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITY IS THE TRAINING THAT
WE DO INTERNALLY FOR NOT ONLY
OUR DEPARTMENTS BUT THE
INDEPENDENT BOARDS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE LABOR AGENCIES
SUPPORTING OUR ALE JAY'S. IN
UNDERSTANDING THE LAWS THAT ARE
PASSED AND ALSO- BE
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH
APPLICATION OF THE- YOU LAWS
WERE EXISTING LAWS THAT ARE
PASSED ON INCLUDING FOR
REGULATIONS- ADVICE LETTERS ON
ADVISORY RULINGS OPINION
LETTERS AND SO FOR- LABOR
AGENCY IDENTIFIED THIS NEED-
WHEN I FIRST CAME ON BOARD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WITH OUR
IMPLEMENTATION. EIGHTY FIVE-
AND ALTHOUGH WE DID STEM FROM
THE WORK THAT WE DID WITH
EIGHTY FIVE WITH OUR UNITS- THE
NEED CONTINUES- AS WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC- WITH
VARIOUS ACROSS. DEPARTMENTAL
EFFORT. I'M ALSO AFTERWARDS
WITHIN THE- SO AGAIN THAT IS A
SUMMARY OF THE PROPOSED AND-
HOLD GOING AND STOP THEIR ALL
RIGHT FOR. MY OTHER PANELISTS
TO KIND OF ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDER. AND THE
TO TESTIFY. THANK FOR THAT
HELLO. GOOD AFTERNOON WE HAVE
NO ISSUE- THIS I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MENACE. MARK ONE
OF THE FORMER DEFINING JUST
WANTED A THAT THOSE WHO DON'T
FUNDED SOURCES OF LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FUND ON
THE PURPOSE OF WHICH IS TO FIND
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS BUT
ALSO THE EDGE THAT TO EDUCATE
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES ABOUT
THE STATE'S LABOR LAWS WHICH IS
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL IS CERTAINLY
WELL BUT THEN. IF YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS MISTER LUCKY YOU'RE
JUST A REAL QUICK QUESTION. DO
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MUCH
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT ON
INFORMATION EDUCATION. AND
ENFORCEMENT THE AGENCY AND
EIGHTY D. REGARDING AB FIVE.
DIRECTED AT THE GIG WORKERS
PRIOR TO PROP TWENTY TWO
PASSING. AND SUBSEQUENTLY HOW
MUCH HAS BEEN SPENT ON
INFORMATION EDUCATION
RETRACTING PRIOR ACTIONS AFTER
PROP TWENTY TWO. DOES WORK FROM
LABOR AGENCY I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION- THAT
IS SOMETHING WE COULD LOOK INTO
BUT I'LL ALSO MY COLLEAGUES J.
STURGEON'S- FROM LABOR AGENCY
IS ALSO. HERE WITH US. AND
ALSO- I TRY TO PASS OFF TO HIM
TO SEE IF HE HAS AN ANSWER THAT
ONE. THANK YOU QUESTION. CORD%
HI THERE THIS IS JAYNE STURGIS
WITH THE LABOR AGENCY- YEAH I
WE DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY
LOOK INTO THAT AND NOT GET BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF WITH
THAT INFORMATION. THANK YOU. WE
WILL HOLD YOU TO THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I ALSO. A ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BEFORE I
MOVE ON TO MY OKAY. I HAVE A
VERY SIMILAR QUESTION ACTUALLY.
RELATED TO AB FIVE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE WORKLOAD HAS
INCREASED. FOR THE LABOR
AGENCIES SENSE THAT WE PASSED
THE B. FIVE AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME SUBSEQUENT. CHANGES CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHY YOU ARE
REQUESTING PERMANENT FUNDING
INSTEAD OF LIMITED TERM.
ABSOLUTELY METAL CHAIR SO- THIS
ISN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT
PERTAINS TO AB FIVE ON. YOUR
THE WORK AB FIVE APPS YOU KNOW
WAS WHERE THE STARTED IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO SEE WHERE. WE
NEED TO COULD NEEDED TO
COORDINATE AND REVIEW- AND WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS- WITHIN
LABOUR REDUCING THE UNITS
WITHIN LABOUR AGENCY. TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW LAW AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES
THAT CAME FORTH WITH AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. HOWEVER
THE GENERAL WORK IN TERMS OF-
INSURING THAT OUR AGENCY IS
SPEAKING WITH ONE VOICE ON
LEGAL MATTERS- IS IT SOMETHING
THAT IS AN IS AN ONGOING EIGHT-
EIGHTY FIVE WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT- BUT LIKE I SAID. YOU KNOW
FOR INSTANCE WITH THE PANDEMIC-
AND- YOU KNOW WE HAVE ISSUES
PERTAINING TO FOR INSTANCE THE
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY STANDARD-
OTHER ITEMS OUT THERE- FOR
INSTANCE WITH A SUPPLEMENTAL
FEED SICK LEAVE AS IT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR. WHERE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ISSUES-
THAT OUR CROSS AGENCY- DIET-
EXTEND BEYOND AB FIVE SO IT IS
NOT JUST- A TEMPORARY NEEDED AS
AN ONGOING NEED. FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MITIGATING ARE RISKIER AGENCY
AND NOT TIME AND MAKING SURE.
THAT ALL OF US ARE SPEAKING
WITH ONE VOICE. THANKS FOR THE
I A- IF THEY'RE NOT A COM OR
QUESTIONS WEEK MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE. SEEING NONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE WORK FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
BUDGET PROPOSALS. WE HAVE
MISTER RAINING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK FIRST OF ALL ON
BOARD- KURTIS NOT THE NUMBER
WITH ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD MR
LIMóN MR JIMENEZ LET'S BEGIN.
RESTRAINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I'LL STAFF VIDEO AGAINST
IT. PREVENT PROBLEMS WITH MY-
ELECT ELECTRONIC SITUATION-
JUST REALLY QUICKLY THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS TYRONE
INITIATIVE EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION IS FOR OUR HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS INITIATIVE
WE HAVE ELEVEN PARTNERSHIPS
ACROSS THE STATE A BETTER WITH
LOCAL BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS
AND BUILDING TRADES- TRYING TO
PUNCH A TRAINING COMMITTEES
THROUGH THE BUILDING TRADES.
ALONG WITH COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORK FOR SPORTS
COLLEGES AND OTHERS- AND THAT'S
CREATING PATHWAYS IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE. TO GOOD
QUALITY CAREERS IN CONSTRUCTION
SECTOR THEIR SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EXPANDED
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
THAT ARE NOT CONSTRUCTION THAT
ARE OUTSIDE OF THE CONSTRUCTION
SECTOR. OF THOSE OUT FORCE IN
AGRICULTURE FORESTRY
AGRICULTURE IS PULLED OUT SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THAT. HEALTH AND DENTAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. TRADE AND
LOGISTICS FOR MILLION DOLLARS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TO
MANAGE MILLION DOLLARS. SO
AGAIN THIS WILL EXPAND EXISTING
WORK AT THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD-
BUILDING. INDUSTRY BASED
PARTNERSHIPS THAT FOCUS ON JOB
QUALITY IN EQUITY- AND THEN
CONNECTING THOSE PROGRAMS OF
INDUSTRY BASED PROGRAMS. TO
SERVICES. THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. SO THIS THIS HIGH
ROAD AND- AGENDA IS ACTUALLY
BUILT INTO MY PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT THE
NEW DEPARTMENT THAT WERE
BUILDING INSIDE THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM YOUR COLLEAGUE.
IF NOT WE CAN MOVE ON TO MR
ALAMO. THANK YOU SAYS ALTHOUGH
WITH THE L. A. L. R. HAPPENS
HAS NO COMMENT SPECIFICALLY TO
EITHER THIS PROPOSAL OR THE
NEXT PROPOSAL IN THE AGENDA
THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER JIMENEZ.
OUR MARKET IS OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M GOING TO TECHNOLOGY
THIS PROPOSAL IS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES ADDS- MISTER
TIMBER ANY OTHER THAN A FIGHT
THANK YOU FOR TAKING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER THE I'LL TAKE
A MOMENT OF PRIVILEGE AND JUST
SAY YOUR YOUR SCREEN AND
BACKGROUND IS VERY FINANCING
YOU GOT THE BUDGET THE BUDGET
BOOKS BEHIND YOU IN YOUR
CALCULATOR. READY FREDDIE ROCK
AND ROLL APPRECIATE THAT. AT
MISTER LUCKY ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS. OKAY I HAVE
JUST WON A COUPLE OF THINGS
ACTUALLY FOR THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
CAL OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD LOOK INTO THE
PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM TO
PARTNER WITH THE WILDLIFE TREE
TRIMMING PROGRAM AND SOME OF
THE OTHER PROGRAMS SO THAT
CONSTRUCTION IS NOT THE ONLY
OPTION. FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS LET'S TRY TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO REQUESTED
THE OUTCOMES OF THESE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BE
REPORTED TWO YEARS AFTER WE
HAVE APPROPRIATED FUNDING AND
THEY SHOULD BE- IN IF IT IF
IT'S POSSIBLE AND I HOPE THAT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS. THE OUTCOMES B. THE DATA
BE ACCUMULATED BASED ON
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE DISTRICTS
SO THAT WE SEE WHERE- THAT
FUNDING IS GOING IN AND
POTENTIAL I CONSTITUENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED AND IMPACTED
AND HELPED THROUGH THIS
POTENTIAL PROGRAM IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN COMMIT
TO. HI THIS IS JIM RAINY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD- THOSE GREAT
SUGGESTIONS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE
NOT LEGISLATURE ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH NO
ADDITIONAL- MEMBER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE CAN MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. AT THE
INSPECTION OF STAFFING. OUR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS OUR PANELISTS INCLUDE
KßT HAGEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS- DOUG
PARKER WITH CAL OSHA AND MR
ALAMO- WITH ELLIE- AND MISTER
PATRICK TOPPING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTAKEN
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON RKD HAGEN
DIRECTOR OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS- TODAY WE REQUEST
APPROVAL OF FIVE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS TO WITHIN OUR CAL
OSHA DIVISION. AND THE
ENHANCEMENT OF OUR OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROGRAM AS
WELL AS OUR ELEVATOR PUBLIC
SAFETY UNIT- WE HAVE ANOTHER
FOR THE COMMISSION ON HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION FOR ASSISTANCE FOR
SCHOOLS I EAT P. ESTABLISHMENT.
ONE FOR. THE DIVISION OF A
PERNICIOUS STATE STANDARDS FOR
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDING AND
FINALLY A LEGISLATIVE B. C. P.
TO A FIFTY I ARE- IN
IMPLEMENTING THREE KEY BILLS
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE IN SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE. AM I SAW IT WALK THROUGH
EACH PROPOSAL AND PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OR WOULD YOU PREFER TO
GO STRAIGHT TO QUESTIONS I'M
INTERESTED TIME IF WE CAN DO.
THE TWITTER VERSION OF EACH
PROPOSAL JUST REALLY OVERVIEW.
CERTAINLY OKAY SO- THE FIRST
ONE- THE RESTORATION
ENHANCEMENT OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH PROGRAM- THIS
IS- OPERATING UP TO SEVENTY
POSITIONS AND FOURTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION. FROM THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THIRTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION ON GOING TO ADDRESS A
CRITICAL STAFF SHORTAGE OF
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST. AND
SAFETY ENGINEERS- THE SORT OF
THE BACKGROUND TO IT IS- WE HAD
AN INDEPENDENT STUDY CONDUCTED-
WITH CITY AFTER THAT- WALK
THROUGH FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST- AND
IT OUTLINED APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT- NEEDED
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS. ARE AND
WE ARE ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING
THESE STUDY RESULTS UNDER
ADVISEMENT AND- ADDING
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AS NEEDED
IN FUTURE YEARS SO THIS IS THE
FIRST AUGMENTATION WE'RE
REQUESTING OMINOUS. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT. MISTER PARKER ANY
COMMENTS FROM YOUR END. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR BUT NO I THINK
THAT'S A YEAH THE SIX SUMMARY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM. THE
MEMBERS OF. THANK YOU MR ALAMO
MR TOPPEN. THANK YOU CHAD
DELEGATE WITH THE ALEJO ON
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WITH. A
POWERFUL SHOT HUNDRED OF COOL
AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE TUDY ITSELF THAT
IDENTIFIED THE NEED TO
POSITIONS AND WANTED TO FLAG
JUST FOR. CONVERSATION THAT THE
POINT IN STAFF THE GENERAL
REGARDING OF WHICH- THAT. CAL
OSHA HAS HAD IN RECRUITING-
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENISTS AT THIS
POINT- GIVEN SUCH DEMAND FOR
THESE POSITIONS AND THE LOW
SUPPLY- IF IT MAY PUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN A POSITION TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE- FOR THE
SALARY- AUGMENTATIONS OR OR OR
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO- ALLOW
CAL OSHA TO CONTINUE TO HIRE-
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST DURING THE
PANDEMIC- WHEN THERE'S BEEN
SUCH A SHORTAGE. THANK YOU MR
IN. THANK YOU BETTER TOP AND
BOTTOM THE FINANCE- NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU COMMENTS MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH JUST A PERSONAL
POINT OF PRIVILEGE I HAVE A
BROTHER WHO'S A RETIRED
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST I MIGHT
OCCUR JIM COME OUT OF
RETIREMENT. OKAY AND ON THAT
NOTE I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- HAS CAL OSHA
EXPLORED HIRING INCENTIVES AND
SALARY SCALE BUMPS FOR REGION
WITH HIGHER COST OF LIVING. OR
TO MR LACKEYS THE BROTHERS
POINT OF THOSE COMING OUT OF
RETIREMENT. SURE I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THAT- WE HAVE I'M
ENGAGED IN SIGNIFICANT
RECRUITMENT- EFFORTS THUS FAR
AND CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY RECRUITING NATIONWIDE
FOR TELEVISION- WE. AND SAFETY
ENGINEERS- AS WE WERE ASKING
FOR AUGMENTATION INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MOVED AWAY FROM
THE USE OF THAT CLASS TO DO
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS DUE
TO- THERE BEING- A LACK OF
CLARITY BETWEEN THE- INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST CLASSIFICATION AND
THE SAFETY ENGINEER SO WE FOUND
THAT ALL OUR INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENISTS WERE MOVING INTO
ANOTHER CLASSIFICATION- BUT TO
BE ABLE TO REACH YOU KNOW TAKE
TO REACH THAT HIGHER LEVEL
SALARY. SO WHILE WE- THIS IS
OUR FIRST- REQUEST FOR
AUGMENTATION FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST CLASSIFICATIONS SO
IT'S A LITTLE PREMATURE YET TO
ASK OUR CONTROL AGENCY KELLY
CHARTER TO PURSUE A GEOGRAPHIC-
K. INCENTIVE FOR INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST CLASS- BECAUSE WE
REALLY NEED TO LAUNCH AN
ADDITIONAL RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
AND GATHER DATA- TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW BACK. AT DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE HAVING
RECRUITMENT DIFFICULTY AND
WHERE WE ARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I'M ANECDOTALLY WEEK WE-
ARE ENCOURAGED WITH THE
CANDIDATE POOL THUS FAR- BOTH
FOR SAFETY ENGINEERS INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST. BUT ARE WE REALLY
ARE FACING LOT OF COMPETITION
FOR OTHER EMPLOYERS- THE
PANDEMIC IS NOT A GREAT TIME TO
BE RECRUITING- INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST THEY'RE VERY- I.
THERE ARE THERE ARE VERY FEW OF
THEM OUT THERE IN THE INDUSTRY
AND DOWN THERE BOB IT'S VERY
COMPETITIVE. SO ARE WE I DID I
DO BELIEVE IN OUR P. C. P. WE
DID DISCUSS THAT WE WOULD- TALK
TO KELLY CHAR ABOUT POTENTIALLY
REVEALING THE CLASSIFICATION TO
DETERMINE IF WE NEEDED TO MAKE
ANY CHANGES. EITHER TO OUR
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS TO
ATTRACT MORE CANDIDATES ON IT-
INCLUDING I CONSIDERING SALARY-
A SALARY SURVEY OR A SALARY
REVIEW- THAT WE WOULD OF
COURSE- IT WOULD ALSO BE
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WE AREN'T ABLE TO
PURSUE THOSE ON OUR OWN WE
WOULD NEED TO GO THROUGH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
BUT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
SORT OF ESTABLISHING A BASELINE
OF GATHERING DATA- REALLY
ENGAGING IN AGGRESSIVE
RECRUITMENT STRATEGIES SO THAT
WE. CAN DEMONSTRATE WHERE THE
NEATNESS. GOT IT THANK YOU THAT-
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE CAN
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
WITH THE SAME NOT DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS BUDGET
PROPOSALS. IN THIS PEN AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT- TO THE
PANELISTS. WE HAVE A AGAIN MISS
KATIE HAGEN AT INDIANA PAYING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS MR ALAMO
AND MR TOPPING THAT'S BEGIN. L.
EUROPE WITH A AND AGAIN. ARE WE
ARE WE DISCUSSING THE ELEVATOR
PUBLIC SAFETY UNIT OR THE
SCHOOLS. I'M SORRY MISTAKEN WE
ACTUALLY MOVED ON WE'RE ON
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN I KNOW
THOUGH YOU ONLY WENT TO ONE OF
YOUR PROPOSALS IT'S OKAY. OKAY
SO NUMBER SEVEN IS THAT PRINT A
SHIP FEDERAL INNOVATION GRANTS.
I'M SORRY I'M TRYING TO FOLLOW
ALONG ON MY- AGENDA. NUMBER
SEVEN IS A THREE BUDGET
PROPOSALS RELATED TO WORK-
WORKLOAD INCREASES THIS
INCLUDES- ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT
AND COMPLIANCE. APPRENTICESHIP
A LITTLE INNOVATION GRANT AND
THE SCHOOLS OCCUPATIONAL
INJURY. AND APOLOGIES I THOUGHT
THIS WAS IN THE PREVIOUS ONE AS
WELL BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. SURE SO AND SO WE
HAVE A PARTNERSHIP FEDERAL
INNOVATION GRANTS WHERE WE'RE
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND. I'M IN FEDERAL TRUST
FUND OF THIRTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THIS IS FOR THE
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS- AND THIS IS A
COMPLETE ALL DELIVERABLE SET
FORTH IN THE BUILDING STATE
CAPACITY TO EXPAND
APPRENTICESHIP THROUGH
INNOVATION. FEDERAL GRANT
AGREEMENT WITH U. S. DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR'S EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING ADMINISTRATION. I DID
WANT TO OFFER IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME THERE
WAS THAT- BUT THERE WAS A
REQUEST EARLIER ERROR YOU KNOW
IT IN TERMS OF EXPANDING-
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES
BEYOND. THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AND- WE ACTUALLY HAVE-
AN INCREDIBLE NUMBER OF THEM
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS- IN
OCCUPATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND IF IT PLEASES YOU I
CAN- I CAN FOLLOW UP. TO THIS
THIS CALL. WITH A LIST OF THOSE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. THAT
ACTUALLY WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
AND THAT WAS IN THE PREVIOUS
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN ENSURING
THAT THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
THAT GOES BEYOND CONSTRUCTION.
CORRECT YESYES WE PARTNER VERY
CLOSE WITH THEM BUT WE WOULD.
BE IN A POSITION TO ADVISE ON
ALL OF THE CURRENT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK
YOU. CHORE. MR ALAMO MR TOPPEN.
CHAS ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE NO
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THESE
ITEMS BUT HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER TOPPEN. SEVEN THOUSAND
ON THE PART OF THE FINANCE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT ON THAT
THAT ARE HAPPENING ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. NOW
AGAIN MISTAKEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR OFFERING TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL INSIGHT FOR THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I THINK ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW AND IF WE CAN HAVE
SOME COLLABORATION WITH THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT MAY
PRESENT THEMSELVES TO HAVE SOME
COLLABORATION THAT WOULD BE
REALLY GREAT APPRECIATED THANK
YOU. SURE LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION- DEBT COLLECTOR
LICENSING AND REGULATION OUR
PANELISTS INCLUDE- APRIL
ELEVENTH FOR THE DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION
MISTER DREW A SADDAM BURKE WITH
THE ALLELES OFFICE AND CHARLENE
MEN AND WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LET'S BEGIN MISTER-
MISS LEVIN SORRY THERE. I AM IN
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS APRIL ELEVENTH AND THE
CHIEF OF FISCAL MANAGEMENT
OFFICE AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. WE ARE REQUESTING
AN INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION FROM THE FINANCIAL
PROTECTION FUND AND FORTY FOUR
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
GRADUALLY INCREASING TO FIFTY
FIVE POSITIONS AND TEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS BY FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. TO IMPLEMENT THE SB NINE
AWAIT DEBT COLLECTION LICENSING
ACT. AND WITH THOSE RESOURCES
OUR DEPARTMENT WILL PROTECT
CONSUMERS. CREATE TRANSPARENCY
IN THE DEBT COLLECTOR INDUSTRY
BY LICENSING EXAMINING AND
REGULATING DEBT COLLECTORS AND
BY ENFORCING THOSE PROVISIONS
BEST BE NINE AWAIT. I WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE BETTY BARNHART ARE
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES. AND
JENNIFER ROBERTS THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF OUR LEGAL
DIVISION WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE OF THIS
REQUEST. WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO INTRODUCE OUR BCPS UNDER
ITEM NUMBER NINE AT THIS TIME.
NO LET'S LET'S FIRST HEAR FROM
THE L. A. O. AND APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE. MR STARR
BURKE. SORT OF BORED ANALYST'S
OFFICE PHONE WE FIND THAT THE
OVERALL NEED FOR RESOURCES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB NINE OH
EIGHT IS SUBJECT TO SOME
UNCERTAINTY STRESS IS BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT NEEDED TO MAKE
VARIOUS ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THAT WOULD
NEED FOR EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT
HAD TO MAKE AN ASSUMPTION ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF DEBT COLLECTORS
IT WOULD LICENSE IT IS SOON
THAT T WOULD NEED TO LICENSE
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND BASED ON
THE NUMBER THAT ARE IN TEXAS.
AND THE ASSUMPTION THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED. TO
LICENSE AT LEAST AS MANY. IN
ADDITION THE HAD MAKE US. ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF WORK IT WOULD
TAKE TO LICENSE AND OVERSEE TAX
COLLECTORS BECAUSE IT'S STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
ITS REGULATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
BASED ON VARIOUS ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT THEIR LICENSING
EXAMINATION PROCESS. THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATED IT NEEDED
SEVENTEEN FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
EXAMINERS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IF THESE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE ACCURATE THEN
THE OVERALL REQUEST INCLUDING
THE AMOUNT OF THE REQUEST THAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING TO SHIFT FROM
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA. CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION LAW WHICH WAS FUNDED
LAST YEAR- TO BE REASONABLE
HOWEVER IT S UNCLEAR WHETHER
OR NOT THESE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
ACCURATE. ACCORDINGLY WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
PROPOSED A LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES BUT THAT IT REQUIRED
TO REPORT. FIRST WERE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT ON THE
NUMBER OF DEBT COLLECTORS WHO
APPLIED FOR A LICENSE AS OF
JANUARY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT COLLECTORS TO
APPLY FOR A LICENSE PLATE AND
SO WE ASSUME THE VAST MAJORITY
WOULD HAVE DONE SO. ON THIS
REPORT WILL ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURETO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT BE SEVEN
THOUSAND OR SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MADE WAS. ACCURATE
AND TO THE EXTENT IT'S NOT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE IN THE
POSITION TO ADJUST THE AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES PROVIDED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. IN ITS. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS. IN ADDITION WE
WRECKED- IN THIS REPORT WE
RECKON BEING. TURNED INTO
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT AS I SAID A SECOND REPORT
THIS REPORT WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO COMPARE THE
AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD IT WHAT IS
IT AS SOON EACH POSITION WITH
EXPERIENCE. WHAT'S THE ACTUAL
WORK WOULD THAT BE CONDITIONS
DID EXPERIENCE- WE RECOMMEND
THAT THIS REPORT READ HE TURNED
IN. TODAY LEGISLATURE BY
JANUARY TENTH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AS IT WOULD PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE DATA WOULD
NEED TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
AMOUNT OF ONGOING RESOURCES THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS IMPLEMENT SP.
NINE AWAIT IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE WHEN THE
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WILL.
EXPIRE I'M HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER MANNING.
CHARLIE MANNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THIS PROPOSAL JUST
HONOR IT REITERATE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES THAT WILL EXPIRE JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND THE DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RE EVALUATE
THEIR NEED FOR ONGOING
RESOURCES SO LICENSE DOT
COLLECTORS AND PROTECT
CONSUMERS BY PREVENTING
POTENTIAL RISKS FRAUD AND ABUSE.
GIVE OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
LET'S GO TO ARE THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SCENE THEN I JUST
HAVE A ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO. THE B. C.
P. STATES THAT THE- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION
INNOVATION GOT THE SEVEN
THOUSAND DEBT COLLECTOR
COLLECTOR ESTIMATE FROM THE
TEXAS PROGRAM. INDUSTRY HAS
TAXES ESTIMATE INCLUDES
DUPLICATES. COMPANIES THAT
CLOSED AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULDN'T NEED TO REGISTER UNDER
SB NINE OH EIGHT. DOES THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE A RESPONSE TO
THE POSSIBILITY THAT D. F. P.
I.'S ESTIMATE MAY BE INFLATED
AND WILL THERE BE A REVISED
ESTIMATE. HELLO THIS IS BETSY
BARNHART. AND I'D LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- OUR
ESTIMATE. BOB FOR ESTIMATE WE
USE NUMBERS PULLED FROM ACCOUNT
OF THE FROM THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU MTV.
YEAH AB WERE BASED ON CENSUS
DATA CITED IN RECENT FEDERAL
RULEMAKING. ON BASED ON THESE
NUMBERS WE PULLED OUR LOGIC
BECAUSE- IF TEXAS I FROM SEVEN
THOUSAND DEBT COLLECTORS. IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE AT LEAST
AS MANY. WE HAVE RECENTLY
RECEIVED INFORMATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COLLECTORS AND WE ARE- IN THE
IN THE PROCESS OF MEETING WITH
THEM IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO. I
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THEIR
NUMBERS CAME FROM AND HOW THEY
GOT TO IT SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEM- WE HAVE CONTACTED
SOME OF THEIR RESOURCES AND
HAVE HAD NO RESPONSE. WE ARE
ALSO TRYING TO CUT CONTACT
TEXAS AND HAVE HAD NO RESPONSE
AS OF YET. HI SO AS FAR AS
REVISING OUR NUMBERS- AT THIS
POINT WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS
THAT WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE
YET ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. NO NOT
AT THIS NOT AT THIS TIME BUT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE- AND DO
LOOK FORWARD TO SEE AN
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. A SCENE
THOUGH ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE CAN MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE. WHICH IS.
ONE SECOND HERE OTHER OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION SHE
BUDGET PROPOSALS WE HAVE THE
SAME PANEL JOINING US FOR THIS
ONE AS WELL- MISS LEVIN'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN. AT WE
HAVE THREE. ADDITIONAL BCPS THE
FIRST IS A REQUEST RELATED TO
INFORMATION SECURITY STRATEGY
AND OPERATIONS IT INCLUDES-
FUNDING FOR BOTH HARDWARE AND
SOFTWARE AS WELL AS A FEW
POSITIONS RELATED TO THAT. OUR
SECOND REQUEST IS RELATED TO
LEGAL DIVISION RULEMAKING
WORKLOAD- AND THAT IS DOLLARS
AND ALSO AT ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS- TO ASSIST US WITH
OUR BACKLOG RULEMAKING PACKAGES-
AND WE ALSO HAVE FOUR FINALISTS
IS RELATED TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SEVENTY SIX AND THE
STUDENT LOAN BORROWER
PROTECTION. LAWS AND NOT
INCLUDES AND FUSED AGAIN A FEW
POSITIONS AND ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TO SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM- THAT ONE WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE A STUDENT LOAN
OMBUDSMAN I'M NOT IS THAT WAS
PART OF AB THREE SEVENTY SIX.
WE HAVE AGAIN AT BETSY BARNHART
ARE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
ADMINISTRATION AND JENNIFER RUN
BURGER DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
LEGAL I WERE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BUT FIRST
LET'S HEAR FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MR
SODERBERGH. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL. OKAY THANK
YOU MISSILE MANNING. IN A
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT
AT THIS TIME BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTIONS AND INNOVATION
BEGINS THE PROCESS OF WRITING
REGULATIONS- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. WHEN IS THE
TIMELINE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL HIRE THEIR OB AND OPENSIM.
THE HARDWARE TO SAY. WHAT DO
YOU EXPECT THAT POSITION TO BE
FILLED. AM I LIKE TO REFER THIS
QUESTION TO JENNIFER FROM OTHER
AYE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OVER
LEGAL AND YOU MENTIONED AT THE
TIME LINES AND- I BELIEVE.
THERE'S A LEGAL I TIMELINE FOR
WHEN WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
PHYSICIAN HIRED. JENNIFER YOU
KNOW THAT TIMELINE. THIS IS
ROBERT- I DO NOT FOR THE
OMBUDSMAN POSITION. OKAY I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU WITH THE REPLY TO THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU. OKAY. WHAT
WHAT- WHAT SPECIFIC DUTIES DO
YOU ENVISION FOR THE UP AND UP
BUT DETERMINED PERSON. I FEEL
LIKE I NEED ANOTHER TITLE FOR
THAT TOO I CAN SAY IT VERY WELL.
SORRY WE WERE PREPARED TO
ANSWER A BUNCH OF SB NINE AWAIT
QUESTIONS. NOW I UNDERSTAND I
THINK- LOOK SOMETHING THAT'S
COME UP A LOT AND IN THIS-
PARTICULAR COMMITTEE S. B. THE
REGULATION TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. AND AS
WE CREATE AND- INTO THE
INTENTION IS TO PUT RESOURCES
INTO THESE DEPARTMENT I WOULD
LIKE SOME CLARITY AS TO WHAT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE. OF COURSE I AM SO I
DO HAVE THE AND REPLY TO YOUR
FIRST QUESTION- EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX REQUIRES BE
COMMISSIONER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION IN
INNOVATION. TO DESIGNATE A
STUDENT LOAN OMBUDSMAN NO LATER
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND DAY EIGHTY
DAYS FOLLOWING JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THEN. WE
NEED A CALENDAR TO FIGURE OUT
WHEN IT'S A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS FROM THAT DATE. RIGHT AND
WE ALSO- WE ARE ADVERTISING AND
RECRUITING FOR THAT POSITION.
WE HAVE APPLICATIONS IN WE HAVE
THE TWENTY FIVE APPLICATIONS AT
THAT'S FAR RECEIVED. MMHM THE
OMBUDSMAN I AM WILL ALSO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HIRING
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND THAT
WHATEVER THEY NEED TO HIRE TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW PROVISIONS OF
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY SIX- BUT-
BUT THE PERSON WILL ALSO
RECEIVE AND REVIEW COMPLAINTS
AND THEN DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE COMPLAINTS CAN BE
HANDLED INTERNALLY AND BUYER
CONSUMER SERVICES UNIT OR IF WE
NEED TO HAVE REDIRECTED THOSE
COMPLAINTS I AM TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. I AM
ALSO WE MAY REFER COMPLAINTS TO
THE BUREAU FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION OR THE OFFICE OF
STUDENT ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF-
STUDY ON THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO BE WORKING WITH EXTERNAL
AGENCIES I AM AS WELL AS HIRING
AND STAFFING INTERNALLY YOU
MENTIONED AT WORK OR HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT AT TRANSPARENCY
AND REPORTING. AB THREE SEVENTY
SIX ALSO REQUIRES US TO SUBMIT
A REPORT TO THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEES OF THE LEGISLATURE-
REGARDING OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE PROVISIONS THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF COMPLAINTS THAT WE
RECEIVED AND THEN OTHER DATA
AND ANALYTIC TOOLS AND RELATED
TO STUDENT LOAN ISSUES THAT
FIRST REPORT IS DUE NO LATER
THAN EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
THEN- NO LESS THAN YEARLY AFTER
THAT. OKAY SO I GUESS WHAT WE
NEED ARE THE ACTUAL DATES ON
WHEN THOSE REPORTS ARE DUE SO
THAT WE HAVE SOME. SOMETHING TO
LOOK FORWARD TO. IN TERMS OF
THE ROLE THE ROLE OF THE OF
THIS PARTICULAR POSITION AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT. I'M AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION RELATED TO
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR WHAT ROLE COULD THIS
POSITION THE OMBUDSMAN PERSON
PLAY IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
REGULATIONS RELATED TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR AS WELL AS
THE EVENTUAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE REGULATIONS. AT EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR IS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION LAW- AND I'M SORRY
YOUR QUESTION IS HOW WOULD BE
STUDENT LOAN SERVICING ON
BATSMEN INTERACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION ALL STAFF IS THERE A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE TWO. IN
TERMS OF THE OMBUDSMAN'S
ACTIVITIES YES- I'M SORRY I'M
I'M NOT I'M NOT REAL CLEAR ON
YOUR YOUR QUESTION IS THE LOAN
SERVICING ON BEDS MEN IS GOING
TO BE WORKING WITH STATEMENT
SERVICING GROUPS- I'M I'M NOT
CERTAIN WHAT THAT INTERACTION
IS GOING TO BE QUICK OKAY WITH
THE C. F. P. L. I'D LIKE TO
ASK- BETSY BARNHART. TO ASSIST
ON THIS QUESTION IF YOU DON'T
MIND. FIVE ONE HEART BUT THE
STUDENT LOAN SERVICING ALMOST
PERSON OR ON THIS MAN- WILL
WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE PROGRAM
STUDENT LOAN SERVICING. AND
WILL CHANGE THAT PROGRAM WITH
THE DIFFERENT- JOB DUTIES THAT
ARE ABLE HAD LISTED- IF THEY
ARE NOT BUT- RELY ON LEGAL TO
OUR LEGAL. DIVISION TO. TAKE
CARE OF THE REGULATION I MEAN
THE WORLD MAKING. AS FAR AS THE
OMBUDSMAN FOR CCS P. L. THAT IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LAW. ALSO IF YOU I HOPE I'VE
CLEARED THAT UP IF YOU HAVE.
ANYMORE QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER. YES THANK YOU FOR
THE I WOULD BUT WE CAN TAKE THE
CONVERSELY- YOU KNOW IN A IN A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF MEETING SO
THAT WE CAN WE CAN ADDRESS THAT
AS WELL SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE- THE FEEDBACK.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. NOW SEEN NONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND FOR MAKING TIME
TO BE ON THE PANEL WE
APPRECIATED. WE'RE GOING TO GO
NOW TO- PUBLIC COMMENT. LET ME.
READ THE INFORMATION HERE CAN
BE ONE SECOND WHILE I GET THAT
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 WITH THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE. FOUR THREE SEVEN
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. OPERATOR
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME THE OFFICIAL THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ZACHRY CORP BUT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION COMMENTING ON ISSUE
FIVE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD BUDGET PROPOSAL. CDA
SUPPORTS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TOWARDS
EXPANDING TRAINING FOR ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
THE LAUNCH OF A TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANTS. EVEN BEFORE THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC MANY
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SUFFERING FROM A SHORTAGE OF
DENTAL ASSISTANTS. ONE DENTAL
OFFICES RE OPENED IN JUNE TWO.
TWENTY TWENTY. EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES AND RE STAFFING
PARTICULARLY FOR THE DENTAL
ASSISTANT ARE REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANT POSITIONS. THE DENTAL
SECTOR WHICH WAS UNDERSTAFFED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC IS STILL
DOWN ABOUT TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
TOTAL JOBS COMPARED TO PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS ADDITIONALLY
DATA FOR MEDIATION THE DALLAS
OFFICES ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING
AT 85% STAFFING. THE PROGRAM
OFFER A PATHWAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING THOSE WITHOUT A
COLLEGE DEGREE INTO AN
ATTRACTIVE CAREER AND A STATE
WORKING ENVIRONMENT. THIS%
TRAINING PROGRAM WILL LEAD TO
NEW JOBS DURING THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
NEXT COLOR. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIC MORE
INTIMATE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
APPOINTMENT OF COLOR AND PAUL
THANK WE URGE YOU TO PRESERVE
BORGEN EVEN FUNDING FOR YOU
COULD WORK A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
YOU AS OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BUDGET PROPOSAL.
REPORTS PILOT PROGRAM TO CREATE
A MEDIA HI ROAD OFF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
HARD HIT BY THE COLD AT THE TOP
THE COCA NINETEEN ECONOMIC
CRISIS AND INFORM BEST
PRACTICES FOR YOU ENTERED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
SHE BEGAN TO CALIFORNIA AND-
WORKERS ARE EXPERIENCING A
MASSIVE WAVE JOBLESSNESS WITH
NEARLY HALF. OF YOUNG ADULTS
AGES SIXTEEN TO TWENTY THREE
HAVING PROPER UNEMPLOYMENT TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY AND THE FIRST
THREE MONTHS ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
THE HIGH RATE OF THE RESULT
THAT YOU UNEMPLOYMENT BEFORE
COPA NINETEEN COMPOUNDED BY JOB
LOSSES AFFECTED MOST IMPACTED
BY THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING
RESTAURANT SERVICES DIDN'T
DIDN'T HURT THEM WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OF AN
EQUITABLE AND BROUGHT BAY CODE
RECOVERY PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU NEXT COLOR. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ADAM CHRIS
PAUL ABOUT OF THE FOR EACH
ENJOY MY COMMENTS IN RELATION
TO ISSUE THREE AND SPECIFICALLY
THE EMPLOYEE TRAINING PANEL ARE
COALITION TO CHIU TREE APPROVED
AND CLEARED. FOR LABOR BUSINESS
CAN AT INSTITUTION WE HAVE OVER
ALREADY FINAL THE SUPPORT OF
OUR EFFORTS WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF BETTER
JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES
REALIGNMENT HOWEVER WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH THE
PROPOSED 20% CAT TO THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED AN
THREE MILLION FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN YET D. D. P.
FACES A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
CAT WE AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT STATES THE GP'S
ROLE IN THE WORK FORCE ECONOMY
IS MOVING LARGE NUMBERS OF
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS QUICKLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT IN SAVING THE JOBS
OF WORKERS THREATENED WITH
DISPLACEMENT. WE CANNOT THINK
OF A MORE WORTHWHILE INVESTMENT
GIVEN THE ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
ARE STATES FACING WE'RE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ETP. IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OPERATOR.
AND WITH THAT ARE GIVEN NO
ADDITIONAL- FOLKS WAITING TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE
ADJOURNING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING.